the following is a presentation of the
St Louis chess
club Grand Masters were on the offensive
at the singfield cup in St Louis most
people dread Mondays but these
competitors were ready to get back to
work following the rest day Wesley so
must like the view from the top
defeating one of his closest Rivals to
remain in clear first Wild Card lenar
Dominguez got his first win of the event
jumping up the standings and into
contention decisive results abounded
will it be another Victory filled day or
will faltering players look to equalize
round seven of exhilarating chess coming
up
[Music]
next
welcome to round of the sinkfield cup it
has been a thrilling tournament so far
and we have three more rounds to go
let's go back to the studio and follow
the
action welcome to St Louis the home of
Chess in America as the St Louis chess
club proudly presents the sinkfield cup
leaders are emerging but time is running
short round seven starts right
now
hello and welcome it's round seven we
are in the final straight and Wesley so
has been making All the Right Moves to
secure the lead but with everything
hanging in the balance and with three
rounds remaining well this race to
Victory is going to be intense I'm
International Master Ivanka housea and
it's a great pleasure to have these
gentlemen sitting next to me sharing all
their wisdom Grandmasters yasa San and
Peter smidler I'm not sure about sharing
I like to hoard the wisdom Joy it's good
to be with you good to be with you too
Peter hello everyone and welcome to my
welcome to my show Welcome to our show
snap crackle pop suddenly everything
exploded in decisive games after the
rest day and wow was it wonderful to
call all the action but after all the
fireworks die down we have one player
who emerged clear first Joy
look at the standings and there we see
at the top of the table it's Wesley so
who has four points out of six after
yesterday's victory over leavon aronian
he's there at the top Fabiano caruana
and lenia Dominguez both have three
points out of five whereas Maxim bashra
has three points out of six this game
discrepancy is because Yang Kristoff
dudo withdrew after round two a story
we've been following is the ratings race
and the candidate spot that's up for
grabs by the player who's number one in
the rating yeah the graphic says it loud
and clear Whoever has the highest rating
on January the 1st 2024 qualifies for
the candidates tournaments it does
depend on chess activity but here it
goes wly so is there with 27 61.5 10
points ahead of Lena Dominguez and Ali
Resa for ARA uh we'll keep an eye on
this all important race for the
candidates but tell us about the format
for the sinkfield cup it's a 10 player
round robin with a classical time
control of 90 minutes for the first 40
moves 30 minutes for the rest of the
game and of course the 30 second
increment or time bonus as I like to
call it from move one no draw offers
allowed and a standard Point scoring
system and as you said it's a race to
the Finish tell us about the remaining
schedule absolutely three rounds
remaining they will be played over 3
days final round is on Thursday November
the 30th and of course plays will happen
if needed great thank you Joy and Peter
you're going to drill down and tell us
about some of the line scores Absolut
let's take a look at how people got here
with three rounds to go and we'll start
with the two players at the extreme ends
of the scale wesle So currently leading
the tournament nobody made any progress
in the first three rounds you will see
this repeatedly but Wesley then uh beat
rard rort for our first decisive game of
the tournament and even more importantly
in round six yesterday he won a very
nice game against his co-leader Leon
aronian to uh progress to clear first uh
in our standings on four out of six
after him we have somebody who is not
really doing all that hot at all and
this is a Continuing Story for the
entire month of November uh four four
draws to begin with for alira fua and
then two very painful losses and he is
now in deadine last position uh it say
tight for th but he is on minus two and
the other two players on two points are
on minus one uh really not going well
for him at all and the two other players
we're going to be highlighting are lener
Dominguez who uh started by uh making uh
draws in rounds one two four and five
and a very nice Victory with the black
pieces yesterday uh puts him in in a tie
for second and as you've seen on the
previous uh in the previous segment also
in a good position for the uh
potentially Fe the rating spot
and one final player and the player
we've been talking about all year so it
it feels uh correct to highlight him
here as well Fabiano Carana who needed
to have an absolute nightmare here for
anybody to have a chance for the grun
chest tour not having a nightmare not
unexpectedly four draws then a buy and
then a win and the last three games he
played were all with black as well so
really good performance from Fabby tied
for second more or less guaranteed to
win the gr chest tour fantastic
fantastic year for him
and uh let's take a look at the decisive
rounds in general uh we've been talking
quite a bit about this because of the
figures uh on the left there no decisive
games in the first three rounds but
we're we're getting there uh one
decisive game in round four one decisive
game in round five and yesterday we
barely had a draw that game was also at
one point looking very very unbalanced
right and we're now above 20% for the
tournament hooray for us
remarkable and on that note uh as as we
see as we see the playing Hall and the
players as usual enjoying the company of
each other this is a good thing about
about these tournaments they actually do
uh like like talking to to each other
and you see players analyzing after the
games even when the game is long and
doesn't end peacefully you still see
them uh sit down and uh uh talk talk to
each other about what has gone before
but yeah this is the this is the best
part of my day introducing woman Grand
Master Anastasia Carlovich uh who will
tell you more about our tournament uh
take it away n
thank you Peter I'm also here not far
away the planing hall waiting for the
players to come over there and give
their comments after the games I'm also
taking care of social media accounts and
of course I'm asking everyone to follow
our social media in grun tour and St
Louis chess club Facebook Instagram and
Twitter are waiting for you um of course
everybody's discussing the previous
round three decisive games everybody is
very happy about that and they're asking
for more let's hope we have another
exciting day today but let me show you
some uh show the inside tour which we
recorded um yesterday let's have a walk
together to the plane um to the area
where the players can rest you can see
that they can have some coffee or tea
also they can have some snakes and you
can see some fruits are there um and um
some small snakes for them um big carea
for the players to stay and to follow
their games while their opponents are
still thinking
it's forbidden to speak there just for
you to know that of course players
cannot communicate during the rounds and
now we have a walk and actually come
back to the playing Hall um so now you
know everything what is happening inside
the area for the players and please
follow our social media once again if
you want to see to see more so and it's
time now to go to come back to the
studio for the 7th round which is about
to start thank you Anastasia always nice
to see what's going on on in the
background there and I like the players
area very much kind of jealous about
those snacks I'm jealous about the
flowers big big pairing coming up uh
tell our audience what they can expect
but this round seven and you see it at
the top it's a good one tournament
leader Wesley so has the black pieces
against man of the moment Fabiano
caruana and then we have leevon aronian
facing off against Anish giri who
remember lost yesterday and pomi is back
to the board after yesterday's B and
this time he faces Ali Resa fuja who has
lost two games in a row what a
difference a year makes peruja our grand
chestor champion won everything last
year just everything he came he saw he
conquered but wow oh it's it's gone
wrong it's gone wrong there we also saw
Dominguez was playing against Richard
report and because of yan Kristoff
duda's withdrawal in round two Maxine
bash the will not be playing today he
has a buy exactly um as we see the
players again just early uh before round
7 all getting their coffees uh they've
been fighting very hard they've been uh
and so have we by the way it seems uh
but what are they fighting for Jo uh a
lot of money look at that let me just
pick my jaw off the floor
$100,000 for the first place second
place nut
$65,000 third place $48,000
as well as those grand chest T points
very important those GCT points you
finish in the top three at the end of
the tour you get $100,000 for or being
first 50 for second 25 for third as well
as an automatic invite to a next year's
2024 Grand
Chester and uh there you see Wesley so
on your left uh not only winning the GC
uh pardon me uh the singfield cup but
also Al uh leading the race for the
candidates yes uh getting uh and on both
level actually that because uh if Wesley
so wins the sful cup he will also find
himself at top of the feed circuit ah
and that means he will have some
excellent chances of qualifying to the
2024 candidates tourament next year I
think if he were to win the fiday Grand
Prix uh chess circuit points that would
be more important than the rating and
then that means the rating spot is back
up for grabs between Anish laner and uh
peruja and the players what they're
doing there is signing a uh certificate
of provenance for the chess sets the the
house of Stanton makes these really
beautiful dgt enabled triple weighted
chess sets and you can own a piece of
History if you would like to own the set
that West so played in round seven
against Bano you can do that and uh
there you have it it's showtime y
showtime and bring it Fabby absolutely
something with the white pieces okay the
AL steps in presses the clock and uh
Fabiano opening up with D4 it's a big
question for
Wesley will he take it easy will he play
solid chess of course course is going to
play the most solid he can I'm just a
little bit taking him back it it was
always very funny I I enjoyed the game
of basketball a lot and it was like uh
the tall men in the center they all want
to be guards and dribble the ball up the
court and the guards all want to be big
men in the center and block
shots Fabby I've always associated with
one E2 E4 full stop end of story E2 E4
is go to opening now he's playing D2 D4
he's being ambidextrious he wants to um
take Wesley out of his
berlins but what he's going to get
instead could be Queen's gabit accepted
Peter could be a nimso Indian I mean D2
D4 hard to be a master the last time
they played in The Blitz Fabby opened up
with D4 yeah no I mean everybody has to
be Universal these days Joy you got to
play Everything yeah I would agree with
you that fa for me in my eyes he's
always been predominantly a one E4
player but uh he is extremely well
booked up can play more or less anything
it's not a surprise that perhaps today
he didn't really want to deal with the
berlins right uh or the anti
berlins uh Wesley interestingly taking a
bit of a pause here I guess he also felt
that D4 is perhaps less likely than E4
and he needs to kind of reather uh his
thought it's not going to be a complete
shock but I I don't think I've ever seen
w take a long pause and move one and
this is this is a bit interesting that
he is now trying to figure out what's
going on well I can imagine the scene
you know he's in his hotel room you know
15 minutes before the game and he's just
looked at every single kind of
Berlin that he could have expected right
he gets to the board there's one D4 on
the on the table it's sort of like okay
you have to completely uh do a rethink
and you have to ask yourself what is it
that Bobby
has seen in my repertoire that fabes
exactly Nimo Indian yeah and Nimo Indian
on the
board this was enjoying a bit of a
Resurgence because at some point I I I
felt that white white players uh were
not really all that eager to allow uh
the nimzo and they would play the they
would switch to the Queen's Gambit up
ideas by starting with Knight of three
allowing uh either the Queen's Indian
defense or there are go in the Queen's
Gambit and uh these days even in this
tournament we have seen a a bunch of
nimos already so exactly seems like
people are less unhappy about allowing
it E2 E3 on the board Rubenstein nimzo
and C7 C5 okay that's old school uh
today castles and D5 has dominated the
discussion we had a game uh between uh
that was the the somewhat strange game
that uh Leon eventually won against ala
right which which
featured no that was yeah that was night
of 3 B6 Queen B3 and there was also a
bishop D2 nimzo in a game between it was
NPI Fab Fabi and and Yan which went
Bishop D2 D5 I think A3 Bishop B7 and
Fabby uh did this here uh which seemed
innocuous but he actually got a little
bit of something there it was actually
it was it wasn't fa uh but C5 is uh is
the choice uh today of Wesley uh kn92
played very very quickly and white now
says I do not want you to double my PA
double my pawns on the queen side and D5
uh very quickly as well this is really
really old school right yes oh
absolutely this goes back to
1978 World Championship matches in bagio
city between look at this you know I'm
looking at the database I can see 1978
1988 game was was there a 20 no 2001 no
I mean this line has been more or less
being forgotten about truly
the the players are in a very dusty part
of their opening library book uh that's
one of the things that I've always liked
about the modern chess era is this idea
that players are looking at the old
books and coming up with new ideas for
example Bishop A5 Peter I I was about to
ask you because Bishop bc3 is your your
standard reply here with the exact
potentially you get something like this
which I believe I have seen before four
black can goes like castles castles you
do want to watch 445 break so they would
Al often just put put the Knight on E7
here unless you're worried about Bishop
G5 which you might be actually in this
particular case so perhaps you do
something slightly more precise you can
start with H6 and then Knight E7 for
instance you can be a little bit worse
but it's not going to be horrible but my
education on the nimzo is not really
very extensive so I was wondering is
Bish 5 playable well let's ask Joby what
does the uh database tell us joy it
tells us that it is playable but the
players have been racing they've taken
yeah like like this is all standard for
them so so A3 Bishop A5 now again
everybody has been playing Bishop takes
C3 for decades Bishop A5 is a different
wrinkle captures on C5 captures on C4
taking advantage of the fact that the
Knight on E2 at the moment is in the way
and after take takes Bishop D2 I was
just going to say that the old main line
was just simply to go Queen takes queen
queen takes d8 yeah and then what
happens and then they play that that end
game so Queen takes and then Bishop
takes I'm assuming G4 I guess yeah
Knight D4 makes sense cuz you want to
rec and do they go Bishop E7 I think
with Knight B7 maybe is a bit is a bit
more precise at least that's what it
seems to be suggesting M B7 it says
white has defin but night B7 with the
idea if white goes C5 C5 C6 we have this
very important move Knight E5 protecting
our weakness on C4 suggesting that
Knight D3 check would become playable
and also provoking white to develop some
of our pieces for us uh so after B7
seems like black is completely okay
because this is very symmetrical and
very level after Bishop C4 Knight C5
Bishop D2 is a lot more uh is a lot more
ambitious here and uh how did they match
up against one another Joy these two
great players let's take a look and
there you can see Fabiano has four wins
to Wesley's five so Wesley there with a
small Advantage 32 draws though I mean
they know each other very very well
after 32 draws Bishop D2 uh still all
part of the latest and greatest yeah
this is now transposed to a more Modern
Line and there I can see that has been
played by vesc ni sarin
FV and a of draws I have to say sounds
like as though it's been very topical
how does the line continue now after
Bishop D2 C uh sorry Knight bd7 Knight
B8 KN B7 is one way to go the engine is
also suggesting something like you can
get the position in two different orders
you can CLE and after Knight G3 play B7
B6 uh she takes B6 uh the idea is to go
for this Gambit preserving the pawn on
C4 because if it survives it cramps
white style quite a bit let's say B
takes A7 we can go Rook A7 and the kind
of a development in particular with the
Rook also coming into D7 black now has
fantastic compensation castling even
isn't even possible because there's
pressure against the bishop on D2 you
can go Knight C6 once again Knight D6
knight5 Knight D3 is a plan so this is
this provides black with decent play for
the pawn so normally you would just take
on
C4 uh
eventually uh B takes C5 let's say queen
C2 you're keeping some options of
castling Queen Side open but with the B
file semi open I don't think we're doing
that we're probably still castling King
side black has a suat weaken Pawn on C5
right there will be something for white
to play but generally speaking some kind
of position like this I would assume is
not going to be very bad for black at
all because there's a very decent
diagonal for this bishop this bishop
could return to C7 uh forming a very
nice pairing looking at the white king I
think they're called horvit Bishops
right the the Bishops on B7 and C7 or D3
and B2 for white very often yeah end
game's probably are a little bit better
for white but we're a long way away from
an end game here uh but I think haab
will not be dissatisfied with this as
well plenty of pieces left on the board
a lot of complicated ideas uh just a
playable position and playable positions
are the name of the game in modern
opening Theory I feel portend are good
for us joy as we're we're hoping for a
great Clash uh between our tournament
leaders Wesley so again comes into this
round with a half-point lead over Fabby
and yeah well we've got a kind of game
not exactly a Berlin ending that we were
fearful about but really with all the
pieces on the board and for Wesley this
might be territory unknown as well so
Bishop D2 Knight B8 D7 on the board and
this is another another move that Yanka
was suggesting and now once again the
Knight seems to never go to D4 here I
guess because we want to side step
potentially 65 counterplay if we do and
uh this position it doesn't look like
very very much after let's say Bishop C7
Sid stepping the the fork with B2 B4 but
you can probably still claim a little
bit of an edge in a position like this
because we uh very often what you want
to do is you want to play B before sh
the Knight away and then put your knight
on e4 giving the bishop the C3 Square it
becomes a bit of a race because
obviously if black is in time to play B6
Bishop B7 while we're still finishing
development or perhaps Bishop D7 C6
black will be completely fine there are
no weaknesses it's a very symmetrical
structure
but when you have a slight Edge in
development in this position sometimes
it's it can actually mean something
sometimes you will you will be able to
exert some pressure so Knight B7 of
course completely playable early early
uh moves there Knight B D7 you said
Knight G3 Knight takes C5 Bishop takes
C4 why aren't we dropping in on D3 check
I think we A4 check in theend I was also
wondering but then I realized whoops
this this costs you a bishop oh hate
that yeah it's kind of annoying when
that happens exactly okay well
definitely interesting game there and
let's go to leavon Ronin against Anish
giri okay uh looks like an intriguing
position ABS we have on the board okay
pet defense the Russian defense with
Bishop D6 again I'm going to give nepo a
great deal of credit for you know this
bishop D6 line had always been there uh
Peter but it be it has become
the primary uh he's definitely he's
definitely done quite a bit to do that
but it's it's been enjoying a Resurgence
even before that and I want to say that
uh the line that they're playing right
now if we get to once again uh trying to
adequately cover the history of this
line will take us the entire broadcast
so I will say that kn3 is a kind of an
old school approach this used to be very
heavily discussed both with the
inclusion of cd5 cd5 and without without
black is sort of supposed to do this
because you want to develop the bishop
prior to moving the Knight to good
squares structurally if you give black
time to play Knight D7 Knight B6 knight7
and Knight D6 you might even start
liking black a little bit but of course
white will have something to say about
it so Bishop G5 uh chases the queen away
for a while white were very very
seriously uh discussing the move d4 D5
here there have been some brilliant
games played starting with D5 but I
think people sort of universally
understand that this is not going to
give you an advantage against a
well-prepared player Anish obviously
covers that definition quite well but
what I want to say is that the position
after Knight H4 which is the second most
critical move here Bishop B6 a very
clever hidden idea of the move Queen A5
Bishop takes E6 Queen takes
G5 eventually you can do and Knight of
three the game that immediately Pops in
my mind when I see this position is a
very very nice Victory by Nish geiri
himself on the wide side in a Bundesliga
match where he beat Fabiano Karana I
think I was playing next to Fab in that
match if I remember correctly so Anish
has very very good understanding of this
position and he is now defending it from
the other side uh I think Fabi went back
to
d8 Anish himself here goes Queen A5
right uh Queen B3 is not forc I don't
think black actually black is not
developed enough to go Pawn hunting I
think if we go Bishop D3 Queen takes C3
is probably ill advised something bad
might happen yeah like something like
this plus four suddenly wow I was I was
wondering if this was dangerous it's not
dangerous it's lethal ends ends the game
pressure on just lethal so black will be
playing 97 night6 anyway uh but Leon uh
plays Queen B3 tickling the pawn on B7
tickling and also of course important to
point out that this doesn't work at all
it just drops a material so Queen B3 has
been met by Queen C7 the bishop went all
the way back to H3 and I develop the
Knight to D7 honestly looks like
absolutely nothing to me I don't quite
understand why
you know if we Bishop great exactly if
we're choosing between B3 for this
bishop and H3 I'm picking B3 every
single time me too but Leon obviously is
very well prepared he has some idea here
he's doing this for a reason I just
don't currently know what this reason is
and another thing to remark here is this
uh uh New World in which Lewan is a one
EO player is a very confusing world to
me I played so many greenfields against
him which is difficult to do if your
opponent goes one E4 exactly but he is
very very serious in about remaking
himself into into a one E4 player has a
lot of ideas everywhere works on chess
very diligently so he isn't he isn't
doing this just randomly he clearly and
he's played A4 already in this position
he clearly has some kind of a setup in
hand I assume the bishop on H3 will
eventually after G3 will get transferred
over to
G2 and A4 is A4 is a novelty we're being
told by a production team as well so
yeah Leon Leon will have will have some
kind of an IDE idea here as as to how to
press black and perhaps ask some
questions but it doesn't look
Sensational right no we put we put the
Knight on F6 we play f8 but play G6 King
G7 all of those things yes the pawn can
get to A5 but I don't know if that
really exerts all that much pressure in
the black position exactly how do these
two match up against one another let
have a look what are you expecting I'm
expecting a lot of draws not this oh but
that is
defined eight wins to Zer in Leon's
flavor 21 draws though yeah but 10 Z we
call an adoption that means they can
come over and stay as long as they want
uh good customer eight nothing who's
your best customer Peter among the very
top players for the longest time I think
I had the best score surprisingly
against Hikaru once again useful to
start playing them when they're young
right but at some point I started losing
games and it's no longer as Stellar as
it as it was
zow massive isn't it isn't it uh yeah
okay well joy let's continue our Look
Around the Horn here is leavon and Anish
are playing a very theoretical duel uh
as Peter said nothing spectacular in it
at the moment we'll jump to uh the game
between Yan and Ali Raza again what can
we say Ali R has just had an absolutely
torturous November I mean losing 27 R he
started with
2777 and now on the live we saw
2751 oh and putting his rating spot for
the candidates in Jeopardy and we have a
slav defense classical with Bishop F5
Knight H4 this has become a very very
Moder going back very very topical line
uh kramnick and topof from their world
championship match and uh Peter Jump
Right In is this all theor
Theory I used to play the slav a little
bit but I never played this particular
line so I wouldn't know about the
current state of theory uh I think
people these days I see a lot more of
games where white actually kind of Waits
when the C takes D5 trade uh which very
often will prompt black will prompt
black to take on C4 themselves and then
push for the C5 break trying to uh
resolve the central situation that way
and here Yan instantly clarifies
everything the thing to
argue why this may maybe is a bit more
comfortable for black is that if you
don't wait for Knight B7 before taking
on D5 you give this Knight by far the
best Square for it to be developed to
right which is what we're seeing the
Knight instantly jumps to C6 and in this
final position it looks very solid and
the question is how are we going to make
any progress with white generally I mean
one suggestion would be you wait for
black to Castle Kings side let's say I
don't know we play Queen D1 or Bishop D3
may be more
relevant we wait for black to Castle
King side and now we start with G4
Follow by H4 H5 and so on black of
course will have something to say about
it white will not be able to make five
moves in a row here but at least at
least there is now a Target available
for us right but the situation in the
center I feel is stable enough that
black is absolutely not committed to
Casting immediately I think you can but
you can also wait because I think Knight
A5 C4 follow perhaps by B7 B5 making
some kind of an advance on the queen
side and then seeing if it's safe to
Castle King side or perhaps it's just
better to keep the King on E8 for the
time being and see what white
does white has the advantage of the
bishop pair but the Bishops aren't
really that impressive so far no
something you would very much like to do
here is to organize an E4 E3 E4 break
but our opponent E4 is so vulnerable
currently that it'll it will take some
doing I don't quite see how we how we uh
achieve that e easily in any kind of the
immediate future so seems very balanced
for me but Yan is doing this very very
quickly and Al is also not spending too
much time this is this is four minutes
above the starting time wow and uh one
little tidbit that we learned prior to
the uh to the show today which might be
a bit relevant ala streamed title
Tuesday
today which uh he apparently mixed up
when when when the buy for him is in
this tournament he he still to to get
his buy for the game against youngish of
dud and he thought it was today uh it's
not as we can see on our screen he's at
the board yeah so good thing the title
didn't start at like 12 St Louis time
which would have been a bigger problem
awkward yeah I don't know how maybe we
should find out how if he won the title
maybe this is a good port for for things
to come uh but no yeah I think he had to
give up playing right yeah well of
course I mean six out of seven and had
to stop that's an even worse feeling
like he's doing well in the tournament
he's very much in the running for for
the victory in the sort of most
important event of today but I guess
though psychologically you just want to
win a few games I mean actually winning
the whole title Tuesday irrelevant what
the title Tuesday is and uh well it's an
online tournament that happens every
Tuesday there are two there's a early
one and then there's the later one so
I'm presuming that he played the later
one and it's like $11,000 for the
actually the early one the later
one because of Pacific Standard type but
it's like a th000 bucks and so he was
just he thought he had a free day yeah I
I I
don't yeah let's uh let's take a look at
the line score on our screen there for
Ali Raza well again uh not great no
brutal at all especially when you're
raised for the ratings uh two losses
there at the end and there've been very
painful losses as well you know his game
yesterday with the white pieces against
Fabiano was very sharp he was just met
with someone who was in form but Ali
Resa well he did come up with a nice
line today what did he do I did he say I
don't prepare for nepo nepo prepares for
me yeah baby that's what we're talking
um tell us about uh this current
position uh Jo V this uh theoretical uh
duel going on here what is the most
popular move after Rook C8 for Yan well
the most natural move is one that petza
has indicated the bishop coming out to
D3 and I don't think tactically ready to
play moves like Knight to A5 yet not
when The Rook is on exactly Vis the
queen and and I actually have some
experience of playing this position from
the white side of things it's not that
easy for black to necessarily make
progress without committing the king
yeah well let's do it I'll Castle I mean
going to go for it well just show me how
you're going to kill me are you going to
go H4 G4 is that the idea yeah that's it
that's it there's nothing more
sophisticated than we might have to
preface this with a queen to D1 so so
Bishop D3 Queen to D1 just to stop
Knight A5 okay I but I have H4 G4 in my
pocket and it's coming your way yeah
yeah yeah yeah as advertised H4 and G4
and what does the theory tell us about
this uh does white win the majority the
games or what's happening here I think
there's very few so we can't really
draw kind of big conclusions from this
but if if we put the moves Bishop D3
castles and queen D1 on our screen our
engine here which some players who've
been doing doing interviews in in in
Anastasia Studio have been saying yeah
like our engine is better than this
engine this is still a decent engine
okay it seems to like this for white now
it says that the threats of G4 H4 H5 are
so quick that perhaps it's time to
immediately start organizing something
in the center following the old Maxim
that you know if you're playing on the
flying come supposed to Counterattack in
the center but white can for now just
ignore it because G5 is a bigger threat
with Knight takes D5 to follow if we if
we chase away the F6 Knight right and
it's not unmanageable but it's
definitely something that white I think
will enjoy more more than black and the
moves that I I see black trying to play
in this position apart from castles like
the best move supposedly in this
position is the move F6 D7 which I think
is not easy to arrive at my guess is we
actually trying to make Queen A4 into
not a check right to play Knight A5
Knight C4 so we we absolutely do need
this Knight on C4 as as soon as possible
and immediately it very much runs into
Queen A4 check and you have to go back
because B5 Knight takes B5 you've
resigned whoops you've just completely
resigned so you go Knight D7 if white
goes H4 once again white is very often
just putting this Pawn on PRI because
the open H file is just more important
than anything an additional point to to
to 97 is we've given ourselves and 97 on
the screen by the way by res Bishop D3
immediately met by KN D7 we we've given
ourself an additional idea here of
playing Queen B6 and asking do you want
to drop back to D1 and allow us to now
we can take on H4 now in some positions
Bishop A3 will become a question and so
on so it preserves flexibility it
doesn't give white a very obvious Target
on the king side of of the king being on
G8 and also it does seem like a res just
knows because this is not not a random
thing this is a very much a suggestion
of of the engine and 92 also played very
very quickly by by uh Yan indicating
that perhaps E34 is now playable on on
his men yeah and this could become
become very sharp yeah look at how fast
this this is all Theory right I we yeah
yeah we we we earlier saw games who are
we following huh who are we following
who are the actually he picaro against
um um where Fabiano
wikis I got distracted there because I
looked at looked at the screen and
suddenly I'm seeing A4 and still yeah
after the move uh that wasn't we were
taught in in school we we were told not
to push the Pawns in front ofely
concrete and considering how quickly
both of them are playing I have a
feeling that this line that I see on my
screen might be relevant and it's
fantastic please B takes A4 already
played by Queen takes A4 now there is
this massive problem along the C file I
think which I think makes the next move
just absolutely forced because you
cannot afford allowing like Rook C2 Rook
hc1 you will just so you have to play
Knight B6 tickling the if the queen goes
back black has solved many of his
problems and also as you said playing on
the queen side maybe he not such a good
idea and then not making any progress is
not really making too much sense here so
we take on A6 to at least have something
and we also create a very important
threat of Bishop D3 B5 which will secure
everything Rook A8 seemingly blundering
stuff and then just King D7 is the
engine suggestion here stepping into
stepping into the
spin sort of full
heartedly and saying and then we want to
go Rook Rook H B8 and then like if we
continue with this after Rook hb8 Rook H
C1 Knight C4 no it's still playable
because you can take with one C4 with
the bishop and of course Rook B5 bishop5
is completely lost but for instance
there's this move Queen A7 here uh which
as Vector cor would say with unpleasant
Sensations and for instance here black
just very calmly goes into this end game
yes black is a pawn down but
structurally this is very very nice for
black this is a much Superior Bishop to
this one the King on B1 isn't very safe
and the threats aren't really apart from
this very nice idea that I can see on my
screen here after something like D1
perhaps intending to bring this over to
D3 that goes Knight
A7 and the idea of Knight B5 Knight A3
if it lands could be very very painful
to such an extent that the suggestion is
maybe even to go Knight C3 Knight C6
Knight D2 because allowing Knight B4 is
also not going to be much fun and whoa
while I was giving this speech brilliant
speech by we're already here we're
already players have arrived yeah no
they it's very clear that they have a
kind of an agreement that this is a
critical line they have both looked
looked at it there's no way you can
arrive here in 10 minutes without this
being
something yeah and this is still very
very theoretical there's uh more than 20
games have already reached W but I can
tell you all of those games with the
exception of one yes finished in a draw
which indicates to me that there is a
repetition somewhere along such as what
uh Peter was showing Knight A7 and
Knight C6 King
D7 you know and here there's nothing
about strategy it it's actually just
sheer calculation I mean everything is
move after move after move Rook C3 Rook
C3 already played I'm trying to figure
out what the difference would be if we
go Rook H C8 now after Rook C1 Knight C4
and Bishop C4 black is in trouble
because I guess the B massive difference
is we've given ourselves a square on C
Queen A7 we just lose to Bishop takes D5
cuz this is no longer made right uh very
important difference between Rook C2 and
Rook C3 uh so much so that the
suggestion is to go Knight A4 that would
be a drawback to Rook C3 because the
Rook can be immediately attacked by by
the Knight you can play Rook B3 but that
appears to not give you any advantage
and the main move here is Rook C6 que
and Rook C1 forcing black to go into
this end game okay and it's an exchange
for a pawn yeah but there's a knight on
A4 which is very very misplaced so you
can play Rook C6 cutting off the final
Square I think if the pawn is on H3 here
white might be winning but black can
start by going Knight B2 and Rook H2 and
uh the King on d8 seems not very safe
but there is no way to give any checks
to it like the only Square to give a
check from is A5 it's very well covered
G3 is hanging so you can go G3 so G2 is
hanging and in this position the engine
says this is fairly balanced and starts
giving choices to Black until that
moment it can I ask why did Black jet Us
in the night yeah was it if you start if
you start with Rook takes H2 a pawn
survives on the queen side ah and this
is more important than the G Pawn not
surviving mhm you very much want yeah
you very much want not to give light a
passer uh he can exploit on the other
side of the
board by the way Rook C3 as played by
Yan we're still in the theory this is
still part of that 20 games uh played uh
Joy yeah and uh well very interesting
position let's check out their lifetime
scores against each other and what are
we expecting not so many games not so
many games in fact just five in total
but of those five games this is pretty
impressive that that you still seven
421 four wins to it's
okay A Very combative games very
competive I mean one draw these guys
don't like uh they don't like draws six
six out of seven decisive games is kind
of unbelievable for for two players of
such caliber but exactly yeah promises
promises good things although this being
as heavily theoretical as it very
obviously is yes perhaps today we will
see a just a correctly played game um
Rook C3 for the first time in this game
finally forced ala to think well
remember I'm pretty sure he's not
actually trying to calculate from
scratch he's trying to remember what the
file says
uh Rook H Rook hc8 with the intention of
protecting C6 and then playing Queen A7
appears to be playable at least for the
time being and also the lines are quite
outlandish here because in response why
just takes on C6 and then abandons this
Rook all together says bringing the king
over to safety more important than the
exchange here black needs to play Knight
C4 here and after Bishop takes C4 D5 e
D5 Knight D4 black is just in time to
simplify and you will have to defend the
pawn down ending because very
importantly white is just in time to
play B2 B3 here using the pin but you're
also not really winning
this black needs to play really really
poorly from here I feel to lose the four
against three on one side with the
Bishops of the uh the same color the
dark Square Bishop here and
here very famously I think uh Peter Leo
won one of these against Vladimir Kik in
brago but yeah the structure was
different and interestingly in that game
White had a doubled Pawn on the king
side and that actually made defense more
difficult because you can push them as a
kind of more of a group but this this
looks like this should be reasonably
comfortably holdable wow what a tabia
that they're playing a tabia position
opening position they're just like
complicated positioning voluntarily go
into a memory
fast well I mean the the point is is
today's modern players their files are
so extensive they're they're literally
looking at openings into endings the
transition transitions from the openings
are so deep they go not just into the
middle games but far beyond the middle
games Rook C3 and I'm just stopping here
and I'm thinking about this because
again you know this is one of those
positions where it's just Rock Solid
calculation and it's like this black
king on D7 for some strange reason is
not as vulnerable as somehow this King
on B1 which has a little bit more
shelter we're seeing these ideas with
queen A7 Rook C8 and queen
A7 uh but you know my instinct would be
that this King on D7 should be you know
ransacked not just you know it should be
destroyed abely but it's hanging in
there4 chosen yeah clearly they're line
yeah and you and you gave us the line
and the longer the engine thinks about
playing Rook B3 here the less it likes
it Rook B3 Rook hb8 Rook C1 another one
of these really strange lines where
things are hanging and nobody pays any
any heat to it Rook B5 Bishop takes B5
is a bit too early for black it's still
playable but there is no particular
reason to give this white unchallenged
because the queen really isn't running
away so currently it starts by playing
Bishop D6 in this position and chill
white white Ste can't really do anything
the the main two moves here i34 and
Bishop B4 but after both of those black
enjoys a little advantage and yeah uh
was very very unlikely uh that Yan would
not go into the line that we were
indicating and they're already
progressing towards it at break neck
speed we are what half an hour into the
round this is move 24 maybe even not
half an hour right maybe maybe
C6 trapping the Knight on A4 B2 B3 huge
threat because then we will keep our
queenside Pawn M so we're expecting
Knight B2 and Rook H2 Knight B2 is uh
and have games been played in that
position Joy yes um how many games quite
a few games wow I see
that
screen wow
16 games with what would be what would
be the highest rated what the if you can
if you can
see actually not so high rated but we do
have a very strong Monica suko polish
grandmas faced off against G mammad Sada
that was in 2022 and there Monica won
with the white side with the white side
yeah
exactly well uh we have prepared that
thanks to Ben Underwood our uh stat
statistician easy for me to say uh some
decisive rounds throughout the years
let's have a look at see how in the
singfield cups of years we' get these
rounds and the performances of the
players and there you can see in 2015
was a very combative year but uh 2022
31. 11% by 2018 the players have learned
the art of
Defense to such a degree nobody could
win and how does our tournament compare
well we weren't comparing very well and
the first three rounds sorry yeah know
but it's very interesting we've made an
improvement over 2018 right cuz that
under 20% we're beating that we're
killing it we're beating that say 2015
that it was so Comba full of decisive
results and then it's kind of gone up
and down you haven't seen like a solid
trajectory anywhere well the thrill of a
singfield cup with such a huge prize
fund and players and we remember the
streak of um
uh Fabby uh Knight takes B2 has
advertised Peter yeah you you you can't
not take it of course because allowing
it to escape by the C4 Square would be
would be bad so we do take of course
black should pick up the poon H2 once
again if you don't you will eventually
lose I'm expecting G3 there's also an
immediate repetition available here if
Yan wants it uh because after Rook B6
the threat of Rook
B7 and then Rook G7 is so strong that
black needs to reactor by playing King
C7 and then we uh we have a reasonably
logical repetition because the engine is
suggesting white it just isn't better at
all after G3 and says Rook F2 is
playable even a kind of a strange
maneuver here of playing Bishop G5 I'm
not sure what threat is being created
Bishop G5 provoking a four and then
going back I don't know why a four is
bad I don't know why but I think I think
the conclusion we draw from this is
black can give white two moves in a row
here and still be okay maybe the idea is
to stop E34 maybe this is how we explain
it uhhuh but it is actually very
difficult to come up with a move for
black you know the Rook because the Rook
on A8 is completely tied down very
important to do that yeah that's a bad
that's a bad
thing but uh I mean in order to stop E3
E4 I would find myself drawn to the move
Rook F2 yeah play4 anyway and it become
it actually becomes a bit sharper we get
here we get here and you can try for
instance play mishop F4 trying to land
it on C7 and I should start attacking
the King on on d8 it hangs for it holds
for black because uh supposedly the the
threat I advertised is very important
can just be ignored by the move Rook F2
I don't know if it's the only move but
once again an indication that whatever
white is doing on the queen side isn't
as bad as all yeah yeahh see I I was
thinking with the Rook on F3 for just a
moment Peter I was thinking okay I see
Bishop C7 as threat but I also see I can
play Bishop A3 check with a gain of
tempo to just give my king the E7 Square
so I wouldn't feel sh to and and he want
to start running well I'm not saying I I
I'm I'm kind of waiting for you to give
me a check I get on night maybe an
additional threat and well and maybe
even a bigger threat did I kn3 did I
ruin the screen no good I was I was
worried Bishop C7 we mentioned but maybe
KN C3 C5 is an actual is an actual
and in particular after Bishop A3 check
because if we make a waiting move here
of some sort the immediate Knight C3
might run into Rook F2 check and that
might be uh a bit of an issue uh but if
you if you uh take away the A3 Square so
that you don't have Rook A3 to follow it
up then it becomes even stronger gotcha
and if black wants to continue the game
with moves like G5 I mean is this bad
challenge challenge I mean give a check
C7 and where does the king run C8 King
has to go to C8 and now once again it
says Knight C3 is playable it's not that
bad actually it seems to it seems to
hold it on those squares like if the
bishop Retreats along this diagonal I'm
pretty sure we're going back to d8 if it
gives a check from here obviously d8
will not be available but we can use B7
squares and does white always have a
bailout like for instance in this
position I mean can you can you just
Retreat the
bishop you can even go forward because
after Rook C7 check yes we're going to
lose this this bishop but we can attack
Bishop on B5 and and balance the
position that way uh so yeah Rook takes
H2 in the meantime has been played so uh
we have a remaining game joy we haven't
uh and
our a
car Ian if you want to play for a win
with it's our first carakan of the
tournament so we have to celebrate such
things and it's lener with white pieces
against Richie Richie repor uh the
short uh I call it the short defense to
the uh to the caroan and he said liable
you lialis you know it's the short
attack he said I said not at all not at
all you're seizing the defense of his
white but you know I was I remember as a
younger I was very miffed that short had
been accorded this uh variation in his
honor because I was like literally I was
playing like this as a 10-year-old yeah
but obviously there was
no no no it was it's the kind of make it
up as you go along right cuz if you want
to make it up you're going to go Knight
F3 Bishop E2 Castle KN H4 push push push
right and I was very successful as as a
kid with this type of yeah I mean
sharing of the honors is no no no the
10-year-old the 10y old ATT this move
night F3 to E1 I talk about a telegraph
about attacking Pawns the move the ideas
of G4 F4 definitely on Lanier's agenda
but I just wanted to mention that this
is a very trendy line that Richard has
just employed with uh pushing the pawn
to A5 doing a very quick A4 it's unusual
for to my eyes as well I'm more familiar
with the it's trendy it's very trendy
and it normally has the idea that after
white puts a knight on B3 you just go A4
and then you kind of chip away at the
center with
F6 indeed I'm I'm a lot of Pages being
borrowed from French defense with Queen
B6 but I mean it looks to me kind of
like a
Frankenstein uh A5 A4 Queen B6 a mixture
of several ideas that appear at least to
my eyes to be bad uh when I said
Frankenstein I I wasn't being factious I
really meant it A5 A4 Queen B6 what's
going on Peter them's fighting work you
right bad not not just du bad bad I
don't know it's a the thing about this
line is i' I've played 35 against the
Caro and specifically E5 Knight of3 I I
began by playing Knight C3 here in the
mid90s exactly and then I very quickly
switched to Knight of3 because it kind
of suited me better and also allowed for
like less Mayhem because the KN C3 lines
get unbelievably complicated very very
quickly uh but I also occasionally
double doubl in this with with with
black because I feel that Caro is in
mustn games in particular uh is maybe
the best choice you have because it's
not that easy to kill the game off
completely in the Caro in particular if
if you play five and black just starts
doing random things such as perhaps what
what R is doing here right random you
probably not equalizing but it's also
very very difficult to properly Orient
yourself here with white because you
have so many plans and all of them look
playable and you have to make a choice
so you you start burning time it's
interesting that ler has really started
thinking here because I would have
already been slightly confused by A5
it's definitely not the main move in
this position and it's usually as played
as a reaction to Knight D2 to B3 exactly
exactly yeah with Knight on
B1 you attacking yeah but ler Blitz
pretty much blitzing out Knight E1 and
and C3 seems like uh he expected this as
a possibility today and actually checked
this particular line and queen B6 is the
only is the only move so far that gave
him pause but you have so many options
here you can you can play Bishop D3
which is something that people generally
I think don't like doing because it's
not very aggressive but you still like
you get your knight to a good Square the
other one might come to F3 you play
Bishop B3 perhaps you start pushing here
perhaps actually A4 gives you some ideas
of playing on the queen side this would
be one option option in a completely
different direction would be just to
start pushing right and this is the one
that's always scary right
mhm for for black right yeah yeah you
know the f is coming right so you're
trapping the bishop on the one hand but
you're exposing your King on the it goes
It goes Knight A3 here using the fact
that can no longer be captured and then
this Knight is headed over to the E3
Square supporting the push in the center
now this is all massively massively
sharp and unclear you can also just go
Knight D3 once again protecting the pawn
on B2 trying to develop this one over
there also a possibility that after G4
you don't go back with a bishop but
instead you take the Knight you don't
lose time way and then go H moves like
H5 and then this is not great because
actually this gets just snapped off very
often and this I've learned from even
even in the French very often it just
gets snapped off the bishop goes to G4
and you find out that putting anything
on F5 is not going to be so easy uh and
very often it just means you're you're
down a pawn and your plans haven't
really progressed very far so H5
wouldn't worry me and zly I would be
more worried about F6 because with the
queen on B6 we cannot really support our
I mean white is still apparently
massively better because black is
completely undeveloped and now we
sidestep with the king the Knight has to
go somewhere and we just go C3 C4 or
even Knight F3 Knight G5 Bishop D yeah
you kind of want to take back that porn
on A4 because you'd much rather Castle
the king queen side uh Joy uh lanir kind
of introduced himself back into the
conversation thanks to his victory uh
yesterday you saw in that race for the
rating spot as well tell us about his
road ahead he's in second place at plus
one been Underwood our resident
statistician also uncovered a very
unusual fact L Dominguez is
undefeated in the sink F cup full stop
and in all of the years he's competed he
hasn't lost a single game y that is
really a fabulous achievement I mean a
lot of players would be envious of uh
such a yes but he does have a tough road
ahead though he's facing
Rich Max VRA and Leon aronian right uh
so white today white also tomorrow
against
MBL a double white a double white for
linear there so very promising and
perhaps at this point we could uh
because we have a bit of a we covered
all all four games we could speak a
little bit more at at length about the
situation with the fer circuit and the
rating race so for the rating race
situation seems very very
straightforward uh Wesley is a full 10
points head of lineer okay with uh as
things stand right now this being their
last classical tournament until the
least in question the 1st of January
leas 2024 and there you have it on your
screen thank you very much to to our
production team uh a visual aid to
illustrate the point yeah to illustrate
the point I'm making uh and uh seems
like this is very clearcut but it's not
because there's two considerations to be
made first one is Wesley is also
currently leading the singfield cup
three rounds to go if he ends up winning
the singfield cup he very possibly will
actually head the list for the F the
circuit there is this takes this is
still this is still very much in play
because for instance GES is in
contention there and GES is playing two
classical tournaments in December wow so
this is less nailed on but it's very
possible that Wesley wins the feed of
circuit if Wesley wins the P
circuit the place goes back to the
rating and the next person on that list
still gets the rating spot which is I
think why ala is now fervently wishing
Wesley does well here right biggest fan
yeah yeah he suddenly you know turned
into I think he began by thinking yeah
if Wesley does poorly here I just get
the rating spot but now that the
tournament has gotten to a point where
he's 10 points behind he is fervently
praying for for Wesley to continue doing
really really well and then it comes
back to the rating first of all he needs
to overtake ler right but secondly uh
there is an additional quer there
because if ler actually ends up
snatching the rating spot he still needs
to play one more classical tournament in
December because uh acity reir this is
what we mentioned in passing during the
opening uh the opening sequence uh to be
to be eligible you need to play Four
classical tournaments I see in the time
period that is being counted and
currently is apparently at 3 even with
this included with this included so it
will be very very interesting if he
actually gets there he will have to find
something to play in December okay and
he will have to do well because you
still can't lose ratings so he'll he'll
have to find a tournament to play in
December on very very short notice I
don't know how how easy that is right
and then he'll have to play well in it
but this whole situation is now very
intricate and and there is a lot of
permutation of permutations available
that needs to be kind of paid attention
to thank you for that Peter and then
that that you got from Emil I got some
some confirmation from from the Fe the
side of things yeah
right from the horse's mouth so to speak
thank you uh for that uh Queen B6 we are
waiting for laner at at this moment
after the move Queen B6 I must say uh
for for me again I I'm relating it to
what I would think of French defense uh
I'm not a big fan of the bishop D3 I
understand I'm bringing my knight to a
good square but I'm kind of hoping to
use this bishop as a Tempo Gainer
whether it B for G4 F4 a big question
for
yourselves first of all are we in uh
Theory why aren't I playing Knight A3
you mentioned in passing that if lanir
were to play Knight A3 Bishop takes A3
as a possibility it's an option at least
yeah but uh I'm I'm trying to bring to
take it because the night is going to
come to C2 and then E3 and then support
the porn storm which I'm terrified of
right so is almost ready the play c65 so
you're not going to have a completely
unchallenged time of it pushing on the
king side also the bishop and the Knight
they tend to fight each other for the
same squares right you know
like goes to E Knight goes to E7 blocks
in the bishop and then so if I if if I
go like G4 you go Bishop G6 I go Bishop
e start with Bishop B4 let's let's let's
not
let's go Bishop G6 B and I'm just asking
you are you going to Castle King side
Queen side you're not Castle you will
you will stay Center stay Center you
will really like the suggestion here by
the way oh it says give me them
B Pawn grab give me give me them pawns
wow that's a computer suggestion humans
don't think like that yeah unless this
is UN unless you're real PA pwn Grabber
yeah wow okay so this is very sharp it's
still very it's still very playable but
very very sharp what I want to do is
this is a very exciting position but I
think until such time that ler makes a
choice right we can spend a lot of time
guessing but there's like 10 moves here
you can play very reasonable and there
is breaking news in in the absolute top
game of the round let do it because
after 9 B7 we were expecting a kind of a
quiet game uh five did play Knight G3
and we thought okay Knight C5 Bishop
takes C4 yes you do need side step the
move B2 before You'll Play Bishop C7 not
very much is happening right instead of
all that Wesley played B7 B6
here uh trying I guess once again to
recapture with B takes C5 trying to get
those positions yeah perhaps he
remembered that he has to play play B6
somewhere because as I mentioned uh the
engine does suggest doing this and then
taking with the pawn and Bishop A6 and
gambiing the pawn which you showed us
yeah very nice but after KN B7 and B65
it took some time to kind of adjust to
the new new uh landscape and played
Queen
F3 and this is not this is not a problem
at first I couldn't really understand
what was going on obviously The Rook is
hanging but A6 B no Bishop A6 I I kind
of realized this is a very sematic thing
that does you trapped your own that
brilliant that does happen quite a
bit I was thinking 95 was such a a
fabulous threat oh my word and this is
this is still somewhat playable because
the white pieces are vulnerable there's
Knight E5 jumps Knight C5 jumps and so
on but the engine very calmly goes
Bishop B7 C6 and says yes after Knight
C5 I still have to protect some of my
pieces goes Queen E2 there's B3 V2
there's Knight D3 check but the
important thing about this position
Europe he's down Europe he is down just
let me castle and the game will finish
so this is not great my question was why
is Rook B8 not great because what's
what's the problem there's a very
concrete issue here C6 seemingly we're
just blundering stuff of course no we're
not what queen we just go Queen F4 don't
using the fact that this is a problem
really only move you you can make is KN
takes C6 and now B4 again hello that is
there's no way there is a way out you
can go Queen C7 it does it does this as
the best way and B5 right but it costs
you a healthy Pawn but you you can save
it by moving the queen right I don't
think so and then going B5
so say you go Bishop D Bishop D7 maybe
yeah okay oh then I I'm Still Still
it's going to cost you that pawn there
is just no way to save it so so you get
some position like this in which yes the
king is still on one but the engine goes
like Rook C Rook D1 first you have to
Castle we play Bishop C3 we play Bishop
B2 this isn't the comfy compensation
yeah and we're now one move away from
castling and saying okay I I have more
pawns yeah I sir compensation a quick
question for you uh Queen F4 uh in that
variation and I could take on C3 and
then take on C6 yeah but the engine
actually thinks this is much worse yeah
this is equal material but you're kind
of completely lost because two Bishops
yeah those Bishops are just so strong
that's it just the two Bishops and was
you also the king is still in the center
if if you Castle your pieces start
falling offish B7 what am I Bishop B7
yeah there's also there's also
this oh no no everything just starts
collapsing it it it very very seriously
prefers okay the position of down so the
position with equal material but those
Bishops yeah here it basically says game
is over it's likeus two and a half let's
get back to Queen F3 so Rook B8 which is
the most natural mov on the board is
ruled out but then well you don't have
choices it's those two it's it's those
two you you choose between B A6 is B4
yeah you you either you believe believe
that you will find some tactical
justification for being a piece down
like you you you hope that after castles
the fact that there is still some jumps
available will be enough and I'm I'm
sure you have a sneaking suspicion it's
not but like your choices aren't great
or you go or you go Rook B8 and here you
go for something like this there's still
some count to play because black can
play A7 A5 start digging at the white mm
at the White Queen side I don't think
this is like completely lost and you
lose every single time you get this but
it's not fun no wow uh Queen F3 are we
in novel where did in Noel Noel
territory because when did it happen
well it happened after Wesley's B6 B7 B6
yeah everyone before then had gone
Knight takes C5 very legit looking move
Knight to
D5 or Knight to D5 Knight takes C5
Knight to D5 had been previously played
S8 and B7 B6 looks like a promising idea
if I can play Bishop A6 exactly but
Queen F3 might have
upended uh Wesley's approach Queen F3
engine approved Queen F3 yes very much
so very much so my feeling is that maybe
he mixed up the move orless my feeling
is he's seen this position before and he
remembered Wesley that is yeah he he
remembered that there are some lines
where you're supposed to play B7 B6 and
to take on C5 not with the piece but
with the B6 pa uh and he just mixed up
where and is now
in a very tough spot by move n which is
very unexpectable move 10 technically
and this is uh where in the UK we say a
little knowledge is dangerous right
because if he hadn't known about B6 I'm
pretty sure Knight takes C5 and the game
continues it's a nor position I think
this is the great terrifying nightmare
of modern Grand Masters like you said
that little bit of a knowledge or more
specifically saliently they mix up a
line and then suddenly bang Splat they
just they're they're in some territory
where game game is over they don't even
have to play anymore Queen F3 might end
the game after B6 well end the game is
maybe a little bit of an over statement
but yeah it's a and and it's extremely
missable as well like the the the
unfortunate thing for Wesley and you
have to say that C6 was also pretty
strong because if you can't force white
To Go cakes B6 which you would have done
if you played it with Knight on B8 one
thing I wanted to just to answer for
myself
uh why isn't Queen F3 strong here yeah
apparently you can play Queen E7 trap
the queen and if Queen takes A8 the
queen gets trapped on A7 and black is
doing extremely well so uh the point is
even C5 C6 here shockingly with Knight
F5 F4 would also give white a very
pleasant Edge because if you take on C6
once again you really don't want this
Pawn here you want to be able to play
Bishop C7 so once again you you take on
C3 and play a really poor position
without the Bishops or the engine
suggests something like this where once
again you've lost this Pawn to Tactical
the Tactical details although this
compensation frankly looks of course
much better because the pawn
E3 F2 F4 is not
particularly a good move here uh but
yeah even even C6 was strong but Queen
F3 I feel is just very very missable
because much of your counterplay here as
black is very much dependent on being
able to play Knight E5 and white just
made a move which steps straight into it
and yet it turns out that move by move
everything works out so yeah kind of a
sequence of Unfortunate Events as the
the book series goes yeah for for Wesley
here for for for me I I mean I I'm a
pattern guy I've seen thousands and tens
of thousands of patterns well that might
be an exaggeration but certainly
thousands Bishop
A6 B2 B4 is a very unusual pattern for
me I mean that you know you play a move
like Bishop A6 you're defending the pawn
on C4 and you're thinking how how how
marvelous then B4 exactly and the Brain
tends to just simply go okay Bishop
Queen F3 Bishop A6 done right good good
solution and then it's only when it
appears on the board you realize that
Queen F3 Bishop A6 B4 wow and now you
know Wesley has to be incredible be
pragmatic and choose which one of those
moves is the Lesser evil I I personally
would sacrifice the porn yeah I would
play Rook B8 and go that that direction
because somehow if you gamble the pieace
then when it goes wrong it will really
go wrong yeah true that let's just take
another Gander at that peace sacrifice
though Bishop
A6 uh B4 we aasan so that's one Pawn in
our pocket the bishop goes off the Bo
now the desirable Knight takes C5 what
happens here Jo he throwing a check
throwing a check and unfortunately for
us our King has to remain in the center
King E7 at least the good news for the
moment is you can't just castle and
bring your king to safety as this guy
Sayang so I've
got two pawns and you I don't know B B2
isn't that re is not that really
disruptive yeah Rook D1 is very strong
just simply Rook D1 D1 okay so you're
preparing to Castle but how Okay kill me
I'll
go check can we not keep that one up our
sleeves and maybe sorry what would you
kick the bishop back A6 first yeah I
wanted to okay A7 A6 let's have a look
yeah A7 A6 allows Knight C4 but even
Bish do is very strong is the problem I
think for C using using the X-ray along
the D file
appears to work out for white because
it's the queen on G8 is vulnerable it's
so bad so so so tragic our Pawn's not
already on then we wouldn't be fretting
ourselves over and Knight D3 so Knight
D3 check D3 just King E2 because he also
just King e there's also Queen be7 check
coming in so yeah oh that's nasty Queen
okay uh and again isn't this B Pawn
offering me some Solace Queen
C7 I would have thought so
but it's not enough it's d8 yeah I can
see I can see the ARG still on the board
I can see the argument for this but it
just doesn't seem to be I get in the A6
satisfying on a good day um so Queen C7
let's say we Castle Rook hd8 right yeah
we just it goes E3 E4 specifically to
protect the Knight on C3 here to stop
the threat of Rook takes D2 and Bishop
takes C3 also and then it stabiliz yeah
it makes some really awkward moves
honestly the more I look at how the
engine plays this with white the more I
think I would probably choose this
because it really doesn't look that
clear to me from a purely human
perspective like it goes goes Knight B1
here says I'm completely winning uh
wouldn't have been at all
OB no but that the night is under is
under Fire though in that I I understand
why it was hanging what I mean is what I
mean is like in my in my mind Force the
Knight back the pawn is still alive I
can put it on B2 I have a very very nice
Knight on C5 which cannot be challenged
by anything the King on E7 is now safe I
would feel that you know maybe I'm
making progress right I can see on my
screen that I'm making none whatsoever
but if I didn't if if I didn't have that
I would think I would think like like if
you look at this position and then we
look at this position black has we we
brought the Rook into play we put the
queen on a very nice Central Square we
pushed the back we are getting somewhere
but but like Bishop F4 is a threat
Bishop takes A5 is annoying if you take
on D2 your Pawn is hanging and the
Knight is coming to C4 it just doesn't
work out move by move by move but that's
because once again I'm I'm being helped
but if if I look at this from the black
side like if if I start thinking here
yeah and I'm choosing where to go for by
this point I think I've realized that
IOU I made a misstep and I'm now in
trouble and I'm choosing where to go for
and I have a choice between uh where was
I bling this this position being a down
this position where I feel like it's
probably important to stop Knight E5 so
let's say Bishop C3 and after castles
why just starts developing okay this was
apparently a huge mistake because A7 A6
is not strong so let's include as we
were including Rook G1 castles Bishop C3
Queen somewhere and let's say Bishop
B2 and I look at this and I think I have
like maybe a two move window here with
black to attack something if I don't
attack something immediately I'm going
to slowly but very very surely lose this
game because it's just two against one
no particular compensation you don't
save them very often and then I have the
option of of going for this for this
mess yeah after Rook D1 mhm and at least
for me the instinct is always go for the
one that's Messier right for the one
that's less orderly for the one that
creates right and Fabby is Mr
calculation guy yeah he can get thisp
typ of position and calculate his way
out of trouble true whereas in the other
game it's a lot more fluid right it's to
do with peace activity and coming up
with plans and just never underestimate
the ability of a human to go wrong for
me joy this is absolutely fantastic this
is the type of game I was hoping for the
two players uh first and second uh place
if you will Wesley his road ahead uh
he's at plus two uh he's playing uh well
Mr
2023 fa and he'll have a buy in the very
last round yes I play Nashi and then he
would have played Yan Kristoff Duda but
Yan Kristoff Duda hadn't withdrawn but
he has and so therefore it's a buy
exactly so I mean for Wesley if he could
get through this game it would just be
uh you know uh roses if you will but for
the moment he he appears to be in
trouble this move Queen F3 is Def
definitely uh forced Wesley 30 minute
thing it's it's been a good thing hasn't
it uh yeah and you can just see him
there in the camera just shaking his
head looking very uncomfortable the
penny has dropped you know he's got his
move wrong is in big trouble and let's
just remind ourselves this is so rare
for us uh move 10 I mean my goodness
we've been looking at uh games where for
example the fuia game there are 20 moves
those two games side by side look very
very funny right one Tabby has 25 moves
along the
other only after nine uh 10 moves uh
Wesley in trouble and while while Wesley
is still Ming it over let's maybe switch
over for a second
TOA game because Yan did something we
were not talking about as much we were
looking at G3 in the position after Rook
takes H2 he says we're not here to to
wait we're not here to try to preserve
material and just goes E4 straight away
okay and uh fua finally started thinking
he is now below the starting time he
spent about 25 minutes I want to say in
this position he was at 133 and when D
takes E4 which is fine but now via some
move order they're very likely to end up
here okay and this seems like we're
entering some kind of an only move
territory because uh once again I'm not
altogether convinced by this but seems
like G6 G5 immediately without the
inclusion of Rook C8 for instance which
is looks very very logical like why why
are we allowing Bishop C7 check when we
can stop it mhm uh both are probably
still drawn but after G after G5 Bishop
C7 King C8 it seems to be uh okay and
after Rook
C8 uh followed by very quiet Rook B6 G5
Bishop G3 Rook B7 is a very very
annoying threat and here I feel like we
can actually call the movie 65 the only
move mhm wow with the intention very
specifically of following it up with
Bishop F6 because you need to get you
need to get pieces off the board even at
the cost of this much this much material
I think very importantly white cannot
take on F6 here because Rook B8 and the
double pins could collect collect
everything but yeah so if you if you
play Rook C8 they haven't actually
arrived here yet D4 and I'm guessing Yan
is not at the board oh no he is so he is
DX C4 is not the machine first
suggestion so Yan is probably uh trying
to remember what what his intentions are
supposed to be here and once again to
remind of your this is move 27 they have
maybe finally started playing a game of
chess right they stopped yeah until
until that moment they were very clearly
both repeating uh repeating what the
file says if a four chosen but we assume
it's the same position because having
gotten here how do you not take on G2
indeed so once again Rook takes G2
Bishop G2 Bishop F4 and we get here and
G5 is cleaner but Rook C8 might still
save the game but but there you really
do enter the territory where you will
have to start playing extremely
precisely my guess is if we do this here
oh yeah this is the diff this is the
major major difference you just cannot
put the bishop on g3 at all because you
instantly lose the game to the pin along
the B5 so you have to give this check
and the way to play for a win here is
exactly what you'd expect because white
you know white gave up a pawn to do
something in the center right and that
something has to be D5 D6 D7 and so on
and after he takes D5 he takes D5 seems
like King B7 is strictly the only move
everything else is trouble but in that
getting out of the discovered CH what
what's remarkable for me is this King on
B2 has been on this kind of open Highway
second rank bile it's Untouchable
nobody's bothered the
king and you've got uh a passer up uh
right up the center to to D5 and it
actually becomes kind of kind of
relevant because currently D5 D6
even Bishop takes D6 is playable because
once again Rook takes E2 to follow and
maybe white makes a draw maybe white
doesn't but yeah white is no longer
really playing for a win here this much
we know so no D6 so no D6 and if you
drop the Rook back the king stles
getting chased around of starting with
Bishop F6 check and you can go forward
and then Black Goes Rook A1 Rook B1
check and starts creating issues or you
can go actually C1
D2 which is a reasonably safe nest for
the king but the Rook becomes very
active W and you have to kind of balance
all of these things and also also black
very much would like to get continue
getting pieces off the board so after
something like Bishop D3 it very much it
very much goes Rook B2 and says I will
now hold this because once the Rooks
disappear the black king is never
getting M and the the margins become a
lot wider deor is terrifying it is very
it is very strong yeah you can play
something like D6 here Rook C2 Bishop C2
there's also this threat Bishop is yeah
it says and this is actually a
construction I know from a different
side from the grunfeld D6 with a bishop
on E7 very often if you can actually
kind of attach yourself to the to the
bishop on E7 in particular if you like
if you push the F Pawn play King F7 it
stops the pawn from moving forward and
here we have the same construction this
looks very solid but in terms of
actually queening the pawn you'd much
rather not you'd much rather Bop can
move right but then we'll play King C6
and start attacking it like if you play
Bish A5 here yeah like King six might be
yeah I blunder The Rook here because of
bish 5 check but in in understood what
what the concept concept conceptually
this would have been a good move it's a
bad move but for very specific reasons
gotcha Peter thank you so much and I
think we've come to that point in our uh
show where we start to think about the
break at least and before we do that of
course we have to look at uh checking
with our friends at Q Boutique and see
what's abely what's on tap well guess
what everyone on offer today indeed gear
up in the newest apparel from the St
Louis chess club with this officially
branded puffy vest features the chess
club signature logo cross the left
breast pocket 100% polyester available
at Q Boutique stl.com for all your chess
shopping needs I believe the holiday
discounts are still in I mean this 20%
this is ridiculous they don't get me to
I walk in they say full price man I get
in service time yes like you can go to
QB stl.com and do your holiday shopping
absolutely and it ends today last this
is it this is it the Last Chance Saloon
here everybody uh do your shopping
absolutely and it's time for us to take
a break but uh we have a nice feature
for you lined up earlier on Anish spoke
to Anastasia so enjoy that and we'll see
you in a few
minutes
[Music]
Anish welcome to St Louis welcome to gr
stour part of your persona is actually
in social media and um you have really
individual and humorous tweets and what
do you think I mean what impact social
media uh have on CH players life these
days and um is it something what you
like to do or you're trying to build in
a way self brand through social media
yeah it's I no longer like tweeting for
a very long time but I
um yeah I've sort of built
um some sort of uh you know small chess
uh brand on online and um I I keep the
the fire burning there I think it's uh
it's been very helpful for me um I've
gotten a lot of more opportunities um
because of that and a lot of fans a lot
of support
so you know I'm not like hikaro who who
is really going all out on on streaming
I I wasn't able to to do that um but I
still try to yeah have some online
presence but last year I been focusing
much more on the you know on the
classical chess on the world
championship cycle and it's been very um
very exciting for me so I uh I hope to
finish this um season on on a high yeah
and speaking about the world
championship cycle and in general what's
happening on the top I know you always
have an opinion so can you just let's
say speak a little bit about what's
happening right now last year with
Magnus who withdrew from the cycle with
ding who actually I mean absent for for
long time with Hikaru who still actually
keeps playing quite well so like what's
happening right now what are the new
trends let's say no like as you
mentioned definitely very exciting times
in a sense I mean you've got Magnus who
sort of um
trying
to um not not not retire but uh at the
same
time yeah he's he's you know withdrawn
from certain things like the classical
World Championship cycle and also he's
choosing his events um in a different
way than usual and of course yeah of
course the fact that Ding after his
world championship title it was wasn't
playing much that's also something
unusual and of course that hikaro is uh
uh at the very to after all these years
because he's been there for for many
many years and um it's only after he
sort of stop playing professionally as
he as he says it that he you know that
his reason to S this High although of
course hiari he had his Peaks as well
before I think he won byan tournament he
was 2800 at a given moment um but still
he sort of is experiencing a second Peak
right now and that that's quite
remarkable and we of course have also a
lot of youngsters um that are up and
coming
but it isn't it isn't as easy as as uh
you would expect and many of the
youngsters they have risen and but then
they s of Fallen back a bit as you could
see with ala his rating it went all the
way to 2800 then dropped a bit and you
also have like play like GES AB satov um
they've sort of went very quickly and
GES entered the top 10 even also went
very high but then at some point um they
weren't able to keep up the momentum
because of course it's really hard to to
stay at the top so uh for a while they
they dro the rating a little bit back
but I guess they will keep um moving
forward but more in like two steps
forward one step back kind of um kind of
style so yeah very exciting times uh and
still the players of Fabiano's
generation and doing very well Faby
himself and mostly occasionally Maxim
slamming the door also very loudly in
certain events
so I think a good time to be to be a
chess fan and uh uh also the the world
championship Cycles looking very
exciting so I'm I'm quite curious uh to
see also you got the you know the online
chess movement thing going so definitely
a special time to to be a CH fan where
do you see yourself on in this circuit I
yeah well you know I'm I'm social media
influencer doing uh doing my thing no
I'm I'm doing uh I'm happy with uh uh
yeah with with what I'm doing I'm um I
find playing chest very rewarding and uh
very challenging as well and uh
uh to an extent the fact that you know
I'm not as great as uh let's say Carlson
or some other players like it's it makes
it more fun for me to um to try because
you know I things don't come easy for me
and when I do have a good result I
really enjoy it thoroughly uh it's um
you know when it's so hard for you to to
achieve then whenever something good
happens I think the reward that you feel
is also higher
um I have some experience playing like
much weaker tournaments um sometimes
let's say I played the Championships uh
when the lineup was not very strong um
and then there's a different kind of
event because you are under a lot of
pressure you have to you have to win
usually you do win but of course it
doesn't feel as rewarding so there's not
much to gain so in in my chess career uh
it's very different because I have a lot
to gain always I'm not um you know world
number one or anything like that uh so
there's a lot of challenges for me and
whenever I achieve something local um
I'm just really really happy yeah I
think it's a really good moment to
finish this interview and wish you good
luck in the tournament thank
[Music]
you hello I'm women's Grand Master V
toar janova I will be creating content
for Grand store follow us on social
media and catch more behind the scenes
content the St Louis chess Club is the
Premier chess facility in the United
States we bring the educational benefits
of Chess to thousands of students across
the St Louis area we also promote Chess
at the highest levels hosting all levels
of the US championships as well as
high-profile tournaments that attract
the world's best players become a member
and enjoy perks such as free classes and
lectures weekly tournaments and so much
more visit St Louis chess club.org to
claim your membership today the World
Chess Hall of Fame located in the heart
of St Louis's historic Central West End
want to know why chess has intrigued
people around the world for nearly 1,500
years stop by and learn about the impact
of Chess from our three floors
showcasing the art culture and history
of the game the World Chess Hall of Fame
has something for everyone to enjoy for
more information on current exhibits
please visit worldes h.org
St Louis the chess capital of the United
States it also plays host to an
award-winning shop dedicated to chess
merchandise All Occasion gifts and
plenty more at Q Boutique you can shop
both in store and online from quirky
greeting cards to luxury chest sets
there is something for everyone at Q
Boutique enjoy a shopping experience
like no other make sure to check out Q
Boutique stl.com for a wide variety of
gifts for everyone to enjoy the St Louis
chess club Scholastic program brings the
educational value of Chess to kids and
schools across the St Louis area active
in over 100 schools throughout the St
Louis city and county the St Louis chess
club has been able to reach over 85,000
students in both in school and after
school programs we view chess as a
valuable educational tool learn more
about our Scholastic programming by
visiting St Louis chess club.org
education hello I'm women's Grand Master
rim to janova I will take you behind the
scenes of the grand chest tour follow us
on social media and don't miss out on
players interviews and more content from
the playing
Hall the St Louis chess club is the
Premier chess facility in the United
States and is among the best in the
world thanks to co-founders Dr jeie
Karen sinkfield and Rex sinkfield the St
Louis chess club is a nonprofit
organization committed to promoting the
game of chess locally and
internationally we bring the educational
benefits of Chess to thousands of
students across the St Louis area
promoting cognitive development critical
thinking concentration and analytical
skills the St Louis chess club welcomes
chess lovers of any age and skill level
to come and enjoy the game of chess we
also promote Chess at the highest levels
hosting all levels of the US
championships and the American Cup as
well as well as high-profile tournaments
that attract the world's best players
including the prestigious sinkfield cup
Ken's cup and many more all tournaments
can be streamed via our YouTube and
twitch channels that also include over
2,000 chess lectures for anyone to enjoy
become a member and enjoy perks such as
free classes and lectures weekly
tournaments merchandise discounts and so
much more visit St Louis chess club.org
to claim your membership
[Music]
today hello we are back with our
coverage of round seven of the sinkfield
cup and we have two very special guests
in the studio we have Natalie McKay and
Erin G who are here to tell us all about
the project Teddy and Friends inclusive
playground and not first of all pleasure
to have you here and have how been
enjoying the CH very honored to be here
oh
amazing thank you the the Chess World is
uh pretty uh special when people who
don't have a lot of familiar familiarity
suddenly come into a studio and go oh my
gosh chess is Big Stuff worldwide
amazing wow and so first of all like
tell us how Teddy and Friends inclusive
playground came about yeah yeah Aaron
will tell you a little bit about that
right so I'm Teddy's mom that's pretty
much my only title these days um and
Teddy has a he will be eight in January
he has a form of a condop plasia um
which is the most common form of
dwarfism so growing up it was very hard
for me to take them to uh Community
playground um just because they are not
some of them are adaptable but not
inclusive enough
and so it was very hard um until one day
last July where I met um some of my
colleagues um friends who have kids with
dwarfism as well in the community we met
out at uh Natalie's first playground
called zachar um near Lake St Louis and
it the day was it was perfect we were
there for more than two hours which is
very hard and so he after we get in the
car and Teddy's like Mom that was the
best playd date ever and I'm like it
really was but tell me more why why he
goes I could do everything and you
didn't have to help me cuz I have to be
you know lifting them up on the
playground helping with ladders and he
goes and you were able to talk with
other moms and cuz normally I'm not able
to engage with the other moms on U our
playgrounds in our community just
because I'm helping Teddy so much so I'm
like all right buddy I get it I get it
so next day I research and research and
found that it was um a playground done
by unlimited play um when Natalie is
locally so I gave her a call and kind of
organically started from there she's
like where would you like to build and
I'm like well I live in the Town and
Country depair West County area and
there's currently not a playground
within 20 mil plus around like yours and
so let's start from there how does chess
connect so how does chess connect so the
theme of the playground fast trck a a
little bit um the theme of The
Playground is game board so uh Teddy and
I got on a phone a zoom call with little
T commercial who creates um the
playground um and they're like what
theme do you want I'm like oh goodness I
never thought about that like what does
Teddy like to do and I'm like well he
likes golf tennis chess is a big one and
board games those are his four things
and they're like board games will be fun
and so and CH could be related to it so
it's kind of how it started and so Teddy
is big in um he's only in second grade
so he's been playing since kindergarten
but he plays in local chess tournaments
and so I'm like well this will be
perfect we first started out um when we
reached out to St Louis chess club is um
our Splash Pad will be chess themed
what's a splash pad um water feature
that you kids can run in and in and out
of Fountain you can think of way okay
and the flooring the structure will be
in a chess board ah fast forward after
um some conversations with members from
the St Louis um chess club okay um it
will be turned into after um in the fall
it be turn into a big large like they do
down um in Central West End an outdoor
chess um board right gotcha with life
siiz pieces to use for uh the community
to use for lessons so so that's your
unlimited playground that's where the
whole concept of the unlimited play
unlimited play is the nonprofit I
started and we build playgrounds like
this Across the Nation now and can you
tell us what these playgrounds look like
here we've got some uh sure this is the
design for Teddy and friends so when you
watch there's ramping all the way from
the bottom to the top to the tallest
slide my son was born with a disability
and use as a wheelchair so you can
navigate this entire playground with
Mobility device of any kind lots of
features for kids with autism to play
safely and enjoy what they're doing that
connect four piece has um holes that are
closer together for people like Teddy
who just need um smaller spaces there
and we design it to make sure every
single child is challenged at their own
level so it's not just for kids with
disabilities but look at all the
climbing it's so beautiful so colorful
yeah I mean it's really so much thought
the themes and how thoughtful this is
and how this can certainly improve the
confidence of all the young children and
with the chess theme you've got a chess
board somewhere in one of those Water
Park area kind of splash pads we do yes
this is how many parks like this are
there around the world around the United
States pardon me uh unlimited play is
built almost 100 and we probably have
another 20 under design right now
fantastic thank you how do people
support uh your effort supporting
teddies here locally would be fabulous
so we of course are raising money we
raised gosh the budget it's 3.2 million
and we have 1 million left to go we have
a gentleman who's going to match 400,000
of that right so that can help us
in-kind labor concrete sight work and
then for unlimited play you can find us
on our website what is your website
unlimited.org and a lot of communities
need playgrounds just like this so reach
out and let us know and uh when do you
hope to have the Teddy's playground
finished that is such a
good if it was up to me it be tomorrow
yesterday yesterday yeah I like that
better yesterday right yeah you can
right now we have enough money to put
the equipment on order so we'll put it
on order and then we're raising funds
that 1 million that is going to do all
of the infrastructure and site work as
soon as we have that we hope to open in
the fall but it takes viewers and people
like you guys to make sure this happens
wonderful absolutely thank you thank you
what a project I am inspired I think
that's really really beautiful what you
done you what I've learned there was one
gentleman I was talking to about Chess
and his child has autism and he said
Natalie my son this is his International
Language right it's how he communicates
and it's how I feel about Playgrounds
play is that International Language
right that kids can understand and learn
to play together yeah I can just see
Aaron also like you teddy comes and he
sees his Park and the smile oh
absolutely I mean that's that's that's
worth all of it right for him just to do
things independently especially for kids
with any limitation just to be able to
play independently without a parent or
an agid is huge for them it gives them a
lot of
confidence brilliant one of the reasons
too I also loves chess is something that
he can do yes honestly independently is
a big one for him exactly so Challenge
and win woohoo oh yes he loves it lovely
thank you both for uh coming on it was
really really nice and great success
with the project oh my gosh and for
teddy as well there you go thank you
thank you thank you Peter very much tell
us what's going on uh in the uh
standings at the moment as we resume
have there might be a lot of shakeups
because the positions uh do indicate we
will not have these standings for very
long but for now Wesley is leading the
tournament on four out of six uh Fabiano
and lenier are the closest pursuers on
three out of five and ala FIA is
currently uh at the bottom there two out
of six but also potentially some
movement for him uh I wanted to just
join my voice to thank Nathalie and
Aaron for the inspiring work that they
do I listened to it and was very very
moved by by everything that's being done
it's fantastic uh and these are the
pairings that we're watching uh the game
up top there is I wanted to say hitting
up but honestly not really it seems
settled by by move 13 which is something
you pretty much never say about games
between s strong players we'll get to
that in a moment ran against Anish gir
is quite balanced fua is a fantastic
theoretical battle there and the Mingus
report is uh nicely nicely Brewing
up and uh well now that you've told us
that the two top players are facing off
things are
settled uh it was a 30 minute think yeah
Wesley Wesley clearly missed Queen F3
and I think it shook him more than we
would have expected because is uh the
decision he's taken and I understand not
wanting to be material down but he is a
strong enough player to know that he is
in dire Dire Straits if he does what
he's done uh so I'm I'm very surprised
by this Choice it just doesn't look
right um yeah he could have sacrificed a
PA and do you think as the tournament
situation as well like Wesley he's very
pragmatic risk averse and so he just
decided okay let me just go into a
position where it's equal material but
not fully assessing the real
consequences well yeah what can I say uh
sure nobody likes being material down
but for Wesley especially okay uh he's
just played the move B5 and I had gotten
here earlier and I said well come on you
know like how bad is this and you
pointed out to me that castles we do
have the knowledge of the evaluation bar
and the Machine and the Machine is
screaming at us that this is terrible
for black yeah and B5 B5 perhaps this
explains why why Wesley has gone for
this because if this worked if white
needed to actually Retreat maybe it
wouldn't have been so bad and just to
illustrate why it's so important to
include B5 if you Castle here once again
would have been would have been kind of
playable if not for the fact that Bishop
B5 followed by Bishop takes C6 followed
by Bishop B before takes f8 just
collects a full exchange for nothing
whatsoever so if B5 forced white to go
back maybe you could play but the
problem is Bishop takes F6
Fabby still needs to find it but I think
it's findable if you take for the pawn
Knight E4 wins on the spot because this
is just a maing attack plays itself yeah
and we can show exactly why we've
sacrificed the piece here this is a very
picturesque position so you absolutely
have to take with the queen now the
queen comes into D6 the entirety of your
structure is now hanging you have to
play6 C5 because here you will lose the
Rook on B8 with checks very very quickly
the queen returns and takes the Rook so
you have to play E5 and here you have to
find Bishop takes F7 other moves also
win but this is the simplest Queen F7
queen6 is lost and after King takes F7
Queen
C7 choices are very ugly you can play
Queen E7 Queen takes C6 no no no no
we're going to run with the King
where you're got to run but you're not
going to hide where though where yeah
where the question is the question is
where if you go back or forward honestly
you get you get hit by
the the Knight on C6 Falls either way
and in this position yes the king is
still in the center but the moment White
Castles white has a pawn up white has
the safer King white has the better
light minor piece with the KN coming to
E4 it's just a objective just a dead
loss position you can't really describe
it in any other way so uh Fabi still
needs to find this I mean other options
are available you can for instance play
Queen of4 G5 attack G7 attack D5
attractive only real move here is uh uh
E6 E5 but you're still in so much
trouble after one precise calculation
you need to see that in the end of this
variation you have Rook D6 attacking
both both Knights and once again white
is winning and even if you find none of
these things and go I don't know Bishop
D3 okay here maybe it's somewhat
playable it's still bad because you
don't get to actually win this bishop
comfortably this is hanging so and this
battery will continue attacking H7
you're still in trouble but this is an
improvement if the if the bishop drops
back towards A2 now you can castle and
you're wors but you're alive you're
almost ready to play 6 C5 and this is
the move that black wants to make in
pretty much every single position
blunting the bishop on C3 so maybe
Wesley misunderstood when he was
choosing to play Rook B8 and then to go
into this just how tactically bad this
is maybe he thought he will force the
bishop to retreat and then it's you know
quote unquote playable it's not great
either way but it's not as horrible I I
saw the line Bishop takes F6 Queen takes
F6 Queen D6 E5 Knight E4 and I was going
to give it a rest right there Knight E4
is very strong even F7 is just but the
thing is I would never allow the queen
into D6 you know you're asking for
trouble right G takes F6 walked into
Knight E4 Joy yeah yeah I understand
that and now was getting mated on H6 I
was just wondering whether there's any
like F5 I me but once again5 is you're
an
attacking you're an attacking player you
like you we haven't actually sacrificed
anything contrary you're about to pick
up
a we're giving we're giving made here
and we're and we're picking up material
in the process you know this is just I
understand yeah no I just wanted to just
to see how bad it was it was bad it was
bad it was bad I mean it was so bad that
during our break Peter was cheering
because he was thinking that this will
be the shortest decisive Game and his
name would no longer be in the record
books and uh but but the the the common
theme still still continues very strong
it's going to be Wesley either way if if
he actually takes my crown yes as the
shortest as the shortest L of loss of
all the seld cops he will still be on
all three records he will be the longest
the shortest the longest the shortest
and the shortest Victory just on the
wrong side of it but he was also on the
wrong side of the longest game as well
right so so he's got something to look
forward to winning the longest game of
the S cup okay I'm I think we're in
survival mode here is there no way to
survive this after Bishop of six no you
have to play some position like this and
I'm pretty sure I'm pretty sure my
record is is going to stay safe because
he will play it for 20 moves yeah uh but
the result I don't think will ever
really be in doubt here if you move this
Pawn back like if you play f8 castles
King G8 and then you magically go E5 F7
something those you sometimes save right
but with the pawn on E5 with the King as
as safe as it is with additional
weaknesses that this generates it's just
white needs to lose their mind at some
point not not to win and what is fabby's
uh road ahead uh here as well because uh
for Fabby it's just been one great
success after another after another
absolutely and in his way first stop
it's Wesley so then it's Anish giri and
then finally he takes on Richard rort
which I mean seriously Anish and Richie
are are are tough opponents but they're
struggling in the tournament so in a
sense fabbi is playing best opposition
he could hope for in those final two
games uh and the big test today well I
mean he's passed it to flying colors
after 10 moves
um you you don't want to say winning
position for Fabby but you do want to
say huge Advantage Peter yeah already by
Queen F3 he was much much better uh and
I've been looking at other games for now
but yeah let's return to this for a
second yeah yeah describing the position
after the queen F3 is winning is a bit
premature describing this one as winning
I think is completely Fair as long as he
calculates cleanly from here but another
thing that we were discussing on break
fa and calculating cleanly are two very
closely connected things right he's been
he's been a very very strong uh in that
particular aspect of of our game for
many many years so you would you would
generally assume he will find these
short tactics and U get there uh if you
put the move B5 back for a moment could
wesle have possibly played E5 yeah this
is what I it's very beautiful but it's
just completely lost we play Queen F3
other moves are also strong but this is
the strongest right because we very of
like if if we drive this Knight away the
bishop comes to B4 you'll never rling
gotcha uh and the only reason I was
slight slightly interested in this is
that I thought maybe we play Knight D4
and we get this which is still yeah
which is still
lost but but you can play you can play
but the problem is you can take with
yeah you you can do you can do this it's
stronger than starting with Bishop B4
because we also want to lure the bishop
to G7 okay after Bishop D7 we go Knight
F5 uhoh and the position just collapses
because if you play Queen E5 here you
run into Bishop takes D4 and here
you yeah you discover you discover to
your sh geometry is yeah no the pieces
are just completely Untouchable like the
engine suggests you have to go for this
but you know what this is you have
absolutely no doubt here if you get this
with plag that this is just completely
completely lost right um so yeah E5
Queen of3 if not for Queen of3 if the
queen had to go let's say to H4 and you
had time to Castle this is still
extremely unpleasant right but it's kind
of playable you can start thinking yeah
maybe maybe I will I will leave to to
see another day but no no Queen F3 and
then Rook takes D4 basically ends the
game on this SP wow in the current
position and the fight for first uh
Fabby has come out on top the opening
just went in his favor there was one
incredibly topical tabia game between
nepo and fua uh very very forcing chess
what happened there Peter I think ala uh
I think he was on maybe an hour and 10
when he played D4 and Rook takes G2
right so he spent an additional maybe 20
minutes I don't know the exact number
but my guess would be around 20 minutes
on the Move Rook C8 which as we know is
not as clean as G5 and Rook B6 has been
played very quickly by yan yan is still
on on an hour and 10 so Yan is perhaps
still navigating things he's seen before
in his life I think fora we can assume
that he is on his own MH and this is the
position that I was describing where it
feels like maybe you now have to start
making only moves and the only moves as
we've discussed it's this very strange
sequence which I don't think is it's
obvious so natural yeah no not at all
luring the bishop to E5 and then
successfully trading it because it can
no longer retreat because our Knight is
binned so if you move it anywhere you
just instantly lose a lot of material
okay so whilst this game is following
our analysis let's go over to Leon
aronian against Anish giri that was the
Petra looks like leavon has started to
initiate some repetitions but you said
no ah H5 at least for now Bishop G2 H4
Rook
D3 Rook C8 Bishop H3 driving The Rook
away Bishop G2 and we've caught up with
the players so apparently with the move
Rook C8 that could be an implied draw
offer not that you're expecting that
Peter but what what I wanted to say is
previously The Rook came to C8 from d8
not from h8 so this is a new position in
the game yes Rook C8 will be a
repetition not the third one the second
one but uh for now Anish very clearly
could have just put it back on d8 right
saying I don't mind the draw but instead
he played Rook h8 which suggests that he
at least wants to take a look at a new
position and see if he has anything
stronger than putting in back on the C8
Square uh not surprisingly uh the
players reached the position that you
suggest Ted from a long Horizon ago that
white would put his Pawn on A5 black
would put his King on G7 white would put
his Bishop on G2 they've achieved all of
that but leavon really hasn't achieved
anything spectacular since Peter not not
really um I'm a bit surprised because
there's been a a number of points in
this game where I think starting from
somewhere around here but also H5 H4 is
I think very logical uh because you you
probably don't want with white to even
think about allowing H takes and then
Bishop Queen takes Knight G4 all of
those things so you provoke a somewhat
awkward move Rook D3 right but somewhere
around here I think I will be tempted to
finally resolve this like just to say
yeah let's just kind of both agree what
our structure is on the queen side yeah
let's let's not have any more of this
fooling around right allowing B6 B5
seems unattractive so something like
Queen B5 is likely and then we can go
like CD4 CD4 and in this position you
can go Rook C8 you can also go Queen D7
and say would you like to continue
trading this looks very very safe Rook
dc8 white can although honestly uh it
allows white to continue but the ways
that white needs to play to continue
aren't really that threatening because
the engine start suggesting that we can
now play D4 D5 and avoid some trades but
I think from a purely human point of
view it's just a move you pretty much
never make right because it kills off
your own Bishop I'm not a fan there is a
very very nice Blocker on D6 it just
doesn't seem attractive and what happens
if you were to instead of blocking in
the bishop although it is the
pwn you took the words right out of my
mouth that's meatloaf you took the words
right out of my H HG interesting CU I
was pretty I was pretty sure he tak4 was
the idea the the engine does something
truly spectacular I really love
this it says I would like to soften your
position up a little bit more okay I say
with pleasure Rook takes bishop and now
I go C takes D4 see against C5 takes D4
my intention had been to take the bishop
and then there's no Bishop there's no
Bishop to take and I think this is why
it goes Bishop G3 because if we goes he
takes D4 now Knight D6 Queen D6 and uh
even A6 first my and we will pick up on
D4 so yeah there is this very very cute
tactic of removing the Bishop from the
conversation and whichever way you take
all of your pieces are suddenly hang C4
is hanging you cannot take with the Rook
because obviously allowing him takes G3
is not what we intended yeah and it
seems like they are repeating so let's
go back to to watching uh that's uh
Bishop takes G that's a nice that's a
nice variation uh for leavon leavon lost
yesterday a very uh tough game against
Wesley so he came back today with the
white piece is a little disheartening
here he he didn't get any
but this is what happens when you when
you play against T you have a either a
bombshell idea or perhaps you you are
prepared to play something completely
off bid just to get a game but maybe you
know Anish lost yesterday as well
against Len Dominguez he also needs to
finish in the top four to pick up any
points for the feay circuit right so
maybe leavon was thinking if I play
quietly Anish might be tempted to take
some risks yeah there may have been an
element of the Double Bluff there by
Leon I I like this idea because for for
Anish he is currently in the lead for
the F circuit okay but that is very much
threatened by uh Wesley doing really
well okay and he is still in the
conversation for the rating spot but he
needs Wesley basically to get the Felix
circuit spot for that to be to be uh
relevant because I don't think he's
catching up uh necessarily to Wesley as
is so yeah a lot of players are watching
Wesley very very carefully right now
trying to figure out where they stand
where Wesley stands in just briefly
since that game is over of six has
landed and yeah Wesley yeah that's the
face of a man who knows he in trouble
now understands just how bad his
situation is Bishop takes F6 and uh as
pointed out it's very very nice uh line
G takes F6 Knight to E4 you can take a
bishop but you're not going to like the
results of this one night takes what is
this checkmating pattern called Joy I
don't know I don't think it has a name
we've got names for everything in chat I
mean there's like 29 mating patterns I
didn't know about the 2 33 35 actually
yeah 35 oh gosh they keep growing so
this ought to have its own name uh yeah
Quint takes played of course GF 94 just
looks like the game has finished exactly
so in the game he has taken with the
queen Tak him with the queen fa you will
play Queen D6 Queen D6 will noin a right
to come in with a queen to D6 oh for
sure that's just begging first of all no
escapes uh Knight's hanging with chck uh
Knight can't move because Rook is
hanging you have no time to take well to
take the bishop CU Queen takes and wins
a rook you have to play E5 he he will go
Knight
A5 oh my goodness me no no everything
has gone wrong truly I mean it's sort of
like we've misplaced each and every one
of our pieces so we we've been looking
at E5 E5 is absolutely the only move and
now the question is which one Fabby will
choose because he has about four moves
here which are winning all look very
good including Bishop takes F maybe the
most forcing and I think this one is the
the harshest but I also like and we were
we were also showing this for a second
and then got distracted by events
elsewhere I think maybe a slightly more
human approach here is to to play Queen
C5 B takes C4 and Knight E4 and this is
also just completely completely lost you
have to play Queen E7 you have to play
King f8 here and I mean Knight C5 Knight
D6 even castles I suspect no Castle
maybe bishop B7 we don't want to step
into Bishop Queen D6 E5 on the board
side Peter yeah a move a move like
Knight D6 here although honestly Bishop
F7 is just stronger this feels like if
you allow black to play H5 G6 King G7
maybe might have mind uh yeah I think
Bishop F7 is just strong the question is
how easy it is to see but once again
we're talking about Fabby Fab's been
playing well this year and uh coming
into the day uh JY Wesley's line score
was so impressive I mean he was
undefeated uh things have just been
going his way what else to say I mean he
was on plus two had a great game against
leavon yesterday also had a magnificent
game against Richard report for those of
you joining us late very very
unexpectedly Wesley got himself into
serious trouble on move 10 on move 10 we
were questioning what Favi was doing
playing first one D4 then playing a Nimo
then playing a Rubenstein nimzo then
this whole Bishop A5 and Wesley mixed B7
B6 at the wrong time and he he really
has that look of somebody just wants to
get out of here Fabiano has the look of
someone is about to pounce right Bishop
F7 I think is Child's Play for Fabiano I
think he's going to find that one
especially because it's backed up by
checks uh by the way help me out on this
one you you're looking at this position
for white your your your Bishop is
hanging so you're cognizant of that but
you see the move Knight E4 and you think
to yourself oh that's clever Knight E4
if there's a queen trade I can recapture
with a knight that's a check and I win a
pawn and that's all good then you see
Queen C5 and Rook D6 yeah how do you
choose well this is where I'm doing some
training so I what I try to do on a
daily basis I try to do 30 tactics per
day 30 yes and the whole reason is I
want to go back to basics so I want to
get a position like this okay um what I
want to train on is seeing all the
Alternatives so rather than get seeing
94 and kind of going down that rabbit
hole instead I'm going okay we have uh
94 we have Queen C5 we have Bishop takes
F7 and then I will rank those
accordingly it's just so that I don't
miss those basic moves right so at at
the end 30 tactics yeah 30 tactics 30
tactics per day how many
didn't a nicely done nicely done there
right and does it take you an hour 2
hours I mean 30 that sounds like a lot
of work it's not that it's not that much
I do it in my spare time you know just a
second this isn't a this isn't a three
minute puzzle that you've just put
presented no no no I mean I just go on
to an online s and I just do those
tactics as many as I can and the whole
point is I want to develop a system
because I've very been very disheartened
by my results lately so I figured the
best thing I can do is just simply
develop a a system and then just focus
on improving that system on a daily
basis rather than focusing on results
okay so I I break down this position I
look at this position and I say okay Yas
you're going to have to do some
calculating because
unfortunately uh it's not a narrow path
and there's some very attractive moves I
find the move Knight E4 attractive I
really find the move Queen C5 attractive
because Rook D6 and knight4 D6 as well
yeah and Knight E4 D6 and I find Bishop
takes F7 check also very attractive so
I've got three three really really good
games uh three really good choices I
mean to say and then I have to decide
which gives me the best biggest
advantage of all three and I have to go
through one by one yeah well we are
going to keep an eye on this and maybe
leave you with a cliffhanger because
we're going to go to Anastasia who is
there with Anish
Gary thank you Joy yes we're here with
Anish Anish the game finished in the
draw but first of all how do you assess
your tournament situation and the
overall situation are you thinking about
it and calculating all possible lines
yeah I think uh instead of calculating
the variations I've been calculating the
I calculating the wrong things uh but it
was uh a very interesting situation in
terms of candidates qualification I
think it would be really interesting if
people were following it much more
closely instead um uh you know my
colleagues are stealing all the
limelights with all the cheating
accusations of um in title Tuesdays and
whatnot uh so that's P because I think
it's very fascinating what's what's
going on and um no no we are still of
course course of course of course but
you know the the petitions are the
petitions are not about that so that's
that's that's not that's a but um it was
very interesting because I have um it's
a very complex situation I can um try to
go for the circuit uh could have I mean
tried to go for circuit uh I well yeah
I'm leading as long as Wesley isn't
finishing um above second
here uh so I thought that um yeah I
should have gone for it and U you know I
mean I should I should try to do well in
the tournament so icluded that winning
is better than drawing and drawing is
better than loss as as usual but yeah um
yesterday I have to say um I sort of you
know ignited a lot of complications but
um I mean I have to say l played very
well
um I should have done better I think I
could have made a draw even in the end
uh I missed um beautiful idea which is I
already thought I'm losing and then
still in the end just um before the
final um before I'm already lost I still
have a chance and actually then I think
that he would have um settled for a draw
because it's very complex and there was
a clear repetition there mhm so yeah I
could have played better yesterday but
um overall still very exciting situation
now with uh yeah everybody's so close in
the circuit and in the rating list as
well um and also you know I'm not
tending to do anything oddd I'll play
normal tournaments but um uh it's
possible also to try and um get some
extra rating points like try to play
some um some extra events um yeah I know
it's getting tricky I think that
shouldn't be like that like there should
be some sort of some sort of a set of
rules that would avoid it because then
in the end you can start to like yeah
try to artificially do some weird things
which is fair but just still um yeah
makes it very very odd but uh yeah it's
nice that it's so Clos and I think games
today are exciting and unlike yesterday
yesterday was like the nightmare
scenario for me I not only lost but also
W Wesley won which was very bad for me
uh today though it looks like
everything's going quite well so far uh
I think Wesley is under a lot of
pressure I mean I see this uh I see this
sacrifice on F7 I I mean I was very
confused
because I had a game with Duda um I have
to see from the start this opening
because there is a line like this where
they go bc6 and
bc5 it is very much similar to this but
maybe it's not this because here after
Queen F3 it seems like w was in trouble
so fabik somehow move ordered team I was
just trying to understand it seem this
game is more exciting for than your own
game yes for sure no because it's very
very exciting so C Knight E2
D5 E3 Bishop
A5 uhuh B see DC that's I think the so
far so good Bishop D2 could it be B6
here
B6 here maybe yeah we ask Peter after
yes I it's a funny mixup because or it's
not I don't know like but suddenly like
here the bishop on A5 is okay I guess he
has to still try and gamble this but
yeah B4 is coming and B5 is a pawn down
so he tried to so while this game was
happening you the plane venue you were
checking what's what's going on yeah I
was uh no I mean my game is just uh what
about your let's come back to yours very
solid normally I play very risky like I
play Knight C6 Knight F6 here which
leads to all of double HED positions
today I decided to play more solid I
just play Knight of six immediately were
you affected by the result yesterday
let's say you just wanted to keep it
calm um yeah I mean a lot of uh thoughts
I you know a lot of things went into it
I just liked you know this U this
position I've beaten Fabiano here with
white it's my favorite position actually
with both colors I like to such
positions I like you know uh with both
sides I'm happy with white uh I'm happy
with black I'm happy it's nice you don't
need to study too much if you know
beauti position like that you know it's
just amazing like the opposite color
Bishop nothing's happening I beat F
actually very nicely and um he went
Queen d8 here in Bundesliga so I played
Bishop to B3 and um no one put the
bishop on H3 uh I I think it was good
here like here it feels like I'm under
some pressure
uh because uh it's hard for me to solve
the the tension in the center like let's
say I cannot really go B5 which would be
desirable because of this beautiful
Knight A3 resource otherwise I'd get B5
and KN on B5 it's um very very
unpleasant so um yeah I also should
never go really CD CD because uh it
doesn't help and again like if I do
something like this it only makes things
worse because now he's getting very
active so all these Central operations
are not good but instead I think there
plan of G6 followed by King G7 and then
H5 usually in position like this you
have to make one um uh one active move
and opponent is
already terrified it's already terrified
because position like this white is so
risk free but moment you go H5 H4
already white is like okay getting it's
getting too risky yes it's time to make
I thought he here I felt he's a little
better but um after rook3 he's lost a
little coordination I mean I could go B5
I be a be Queen B5 I think white is
slightly better very very very very very
slightly better here so I went through
dc8 it was very interesting I'm trying
to uh ignite some um
complications I was going to calculate
this business you're discussing with
Leon just 3 CD this Knight A3 move U DC
A6 knight4 but Leon mentioned knight4
right away which is probably better and
I guess it's it's okay of course why
does want to enter such complications uh
he can try to go D5 but I think after D5
I was going to go Knight G4 and um I
have um also some ideas with Knight E8
Knight D6 maybe like a lot of have a lot
of uh play here with the H file and uh
yeah he's he's this passp is a very
long-term asset which is hard to believe
Anish I mean the game then finished in a
draw you decided to repeat I have a
question for you tomorrow is the more
important day you play with Fabby what
are your thoughts with looks like um it
looks
like uh I was afraid of that situation
already but it might we are entering a
situation where it might be better for
M's chances to lose them to drone oh my
gosh yeah no it is fascinating I mean
mean against fa yes for example against
Fab already uh it could very well be
because then um I make him shoot higher
yes above Wesley which is um which could
be important uh so obviously that
creates messed up situation because um
yeah I mean of course I'm never uh um
you know going to play for a loss or
anything like that I'm absolutely but it
just creat is kind of a funny absolutely
crazy situation I mean an are really
looking forward for this game tomorrow I
mean all the best of luck for okay just
so you know maybe somehow I lose that
game it's just because I'm really stupid
not because I'm doing it on purpose but
yeah I'm really curious um I think it
depends a lot on this like if Wesley HS
today he is still in a good shape but if
he Los us it gets very very exciting
yeah thank you so much Anish I'm really
looking forward for this game hope to
see you tomorrow also you're afraid I'm
already talking too much you're afraid
the next time say
the entire Integrity of the the game no
no so okay thank you so much and it's
time to go back to the
studio uh thank you and Anastasia and
let's check out the results so far of
round seven single draw and just one
draw between leavon aronin and Anish
giri a very precisely accurate
calculated game he showed that he was
ready to make that Bishop takes G3 move
very impressive I was I was very
impressed by that but let's let's go
back to the main main event yes Bishop
F7 was found Queen C7 was found and then
the move I was wondering about and the
move really I felt any human player will
make here uh the move Bishop B7 because
after Queen B5 Bishop G2 at least you
have something to look forward to you
you made this King stuck in stuck in the
center unfortunately you lose by force
and very very quickly after Queen C4
check because if you if you move forward
you're just going to get mated like you
you can't really play King f because
Rook G1 or even more painfully Knight H5
followed by Rook G1 you're P down you're
also getting mated quite quickly here
right so you have to go back Rook G1 is
winning but even faster is to start with
Knight F5 the queen has no good squares
we will follow it up with Queen C5 check
and things just start completely
collapsing after King G8 I mean Rook G1
once again is winning even stronger is
starting with Queen C7 out hitting the
Rook yeah you can kind of interesting
you can go H6 here create cting this
weird dynamic of Queen B8 King H7 and
the game sort of continues but now after
H6 finally it's time to go Rook G1
everything everything is hanging and if
you play Rook Rook B7 you just end up
playing an then game a full a full piece
down after everything comes off so uh
Fabby I think will you know having
calculated very cleanly up to here I
would assume he takes on B5 having
played Bishop B7 nobody really plays
Rook hd8 here because why why have you
played Bishop B7 then you could have
played Bishop B6 played one Pawn down
now you're two pawns down right so I'm
pretty sure Wesley takes because he has
basically resigned himself to having a b
position here and just trying to ask
Fabby to out calculate to the end and
yeah I think I think this might be a bit
of a miniature I think my my title is in
jeopard in
Jeopardy and okay let's just run through
that line one more time Bishop G2 Queen
C4 Queen C4 check yeah king is not is
not going to run board it's not going to
survive that one so yeah hide it yeah
you you have to play King f f and as I
said even even Rook G1 now Bishop F3
Knight F5 is completely an utterly loss
because takes G7 also coming back you
have to play Bishop H3 I mean this
position also looks like terrible your
borderline your borderline done here
with like R G3 F3 yeah but Knight F5 is
Knight F5 is just but I think Knight F5
is much more clean because you've got
this queen C5 check on any queen move in
your pocket and you're just uh picking
up more material Rook G1 as needed Queen
C7 as needed it's this this seems this
seems just over because white is white
is a pawn up the King on E1 very
important we have a Pawn on E3 so we
never have to worry about Queen B4 check
so this is completely safe all four of
our pieces once The Rook comes to G1 are
actually attacking the black king black
is completely just discoordinated The
Rook on h8 never really joins the game
it's just over and there's no way to go
kind of go Queen B7 and hold that Bishop
there but what move do you what move do
you make in this I'm just trying to
survive that's all I don't blaming you I
don't have my aspirations on that it's
just you you can't you can't make a move
Knight D6 is a threat with Queen F7 made
coming in I mean queen C5 Queen takes C5
everything white position is just a
picture yeah no it's just it's just over
uh the other two games are still very
much in progress though please tell us
about them uh what is going on in the
game of OI RIS Bishop B8 we didn't look
at yeah G5 has been found and uh Yan
actually chose the supposedly the second
best move here which is Bishop B8 and
the reason I'm saying it's second best
move is that ala had a chance here which
he didn't seize to play G5 G4 I'm pretty
sure he was worried about Rook B7
because that seems a big threat but the
engine suggests now you can actually
return this exchange play G6 I assume if
you play Rook G7 oh it actually goes G3
here interestingly I thought the idea
was to play Rook Rook F2 yeah but no it
plays G3 Rook F7 King B6 and it says the
inclusion of G4 and also very
importantly the point here is we have
this threat right which doesn't win
sorry which doesn't which doesn't win
because of Rook one but it makes a very
comfortable draw so he could have
launched this immediate Counterattack
with G4 and you are very very prepared
to just give up this this exchange to
such an extent that the engin yes this
is maybe the best chance but clearly if
we playing Bishop G3 here we should have
done it on the previous move G5 G4 is
never going to be a a bad move for black
but instead of that ala played Bishop B4
and now after uh let's say King B3
Bishop A5 and Rook B7 you can play
Bishop C7 which is I think why why he
did that but you're still worse after
Bishop A7 because white is basically
threatening to run the D- Pawn down the
board and this Rook it looks very active
but it the N on2 controls it
unbelievably well so it's it's kind of
tricky to include it in the game and D4
D5 is happening quite quickly in fact uh
one of the suggestions of the engine is
to spend these two temp just to moving
it to to to a different
square and it's still manageable but he
is kind of running low on time he is a
full 40 minutes behind on the clock good
thing for him in that respect is that
they made 27 moves in about 5 minutes
flat so he doesn't have very much uh
very many moves to go until until the
first time control gets just to check
after Bishop B4 Rook B7 played Rook B7
immediately I wanted to check he played
Rook B7 immediately but after Bishop A5
shockingly which is strictly the only
move uh Rook D7 is in devast Rook D7
king8 we we we aren't actually winning
anything here right and Rook takes C2 is
now threatened right so the engine does
put it back but then we can run away
yeah we can run but for some reason it
actually likes King d8 better than King
F here which is really shocking I would
be running for the hill exactly I can we
just check what's going to happen after
King f8 no it just says we are actually
moving away from the one big important
thing about this position and the King
on d8 can be a Defender because I think
it's important for us to have access to
Bishop C7 I think that's the explanation
not that the king is unsafe on f8 it's
just that the engine likes having access
to Bishop C7 as a resource very very
complicated position as I said like 18
minutes for like 15 moves here would be
paning stations 18 minutes for eight
moves or nine as it as the case may be I
think is sort of manageable but still
plenty of scope to to to go wrong now
after Rook
B7 uh for for for me uh joy that line
that Peter just showed is is something
of a gem to it because if you look at
this uh position that I have on my uh
analysis board after the move Bishop B8
again Bishop B4 was chosen by Ali Raza
but this move G4 with the idea of a
double exchange sacrifice like just
check that out once more takes takes so
I just sacrificed One exchange and then
after all of these very natural looking
moves here
comes the second exchange sacrifice talk
about a bolt out of the blue and
suddenly the pawn goes to G2 and Rook F1
Saves the Day yeah I mean that's that's
a gorgeous tactical sequence of one
exchange sacrifice the second exchange
followed by our third Rook sacrifice
Rook F1 that's can't stop the born from
great thank you for that uh Peter that
that's really really nice we do have
Bishop B4 by the way on the board let me
go to the current position just uh
Bishop B4 Rook B7 and this is where yeah
Al was thinking
uh the move Bishop A5 Bishop A5 needs to
be played there's really nothing else uh
after after Rook B7 but it's it's kind
of funny you seem to be suggesting that
Rook D7 is not the most po what what
happens if we play G4 here that was my
question now we lose to King B3 and with
the King on B3 after Bishop A5 Rook D7
check King G King E8 and very
importantly Bishop D6 and the difference
is Rook takes e to is no longer a check
let's Che
hang on so here if I do this because
this is still actually kind of unar to
me we have a Perpetual because I can't
run
forward I run forward if I if I run
forward I get I get mated myself this is
amazing this is such an interesting
position and so the only reason this
isn't winning here is because we we
can't we can't avoid the Perpetual
everything else loses it's only the
Perpetual but the Perpetual is available
on squares E2 E1 E3 whereas
if you include G4 and King B3 the threat
of Rook D7 Bishop D6 pretty much ends
the game decisive yeah so you you have
to you have to realize the extent of the
danger you're in and go Bish Bay 5 here
and 16 minutes to do that and what move
are they on again
3 this is 32 for white so nine nine
moves for Al res to make uh real
challenge for Ali Raza and then finally
a game that seems to have all the pieces
everything on the board is between lanir
and Richie this is the Nigel short
attack if you will in or the joy attack
no uh what's going on what has happened
since we left it not doesn't look like a
lot happened L did choose to move Bishop
D3 which I highlighted as a kind of a
conservative option I thought even
taking and playing C5 was playable I
generally don't like don't don't hate
this for black pretty much all always I
feel that these positions are quite
playable but uh rard chose Bishop G six
and then they uh kind of improved the
position of most pieces slowly M black
is playing this does very much remind us
of the the advanced French but with the
bishop outside the chain which is
obviously a huge Improvement and the
current position looks like this um
white has this really awkward Knight on
E1 the way to improve it would be to
play G3 with the idea Knight G2 Knight
F4 if that actually lands and wins the
the bishop on H5 for the Knight why
probably immediately stands better but I
would assume what black does is you play
something like Knight B6 either
immediately after CD4 CD4 and once it's
here I will go back to trading it for
the bishop because you really want to
trade it for the bishop not for the
Knight and then this Knight gets to C4
and those positions those positions are
very sharp yeah uh we're just going to
go back uh joy to our uh crucial game
for first place towards Fabi
Carana because Knight F5 the critical
move is the board attacking the queen
for Wesley so
fans uh big big trouble uh in
fact uh Knight attacking the queen there
just this is just no good squares for
the queen queen F7 again Queen C5 check
what are you going to do you don't want
to go to E8 that will be a fork on D6
you don't want to go to G8 that will be
97 this could be a miniature by the way
how close is Fabby to that
exalted 2800 we've been told that with a
win Fabby recrosses the 2800 rating Mark
which is quite funny because he crossed
it in the aisle of man right but
presumably he lost it later on yeah
after losing to Hikaru Hikaru he lost it
again at one moment I believe he was
2852 I I remember he was like closing in
on um magnus's rating he was number two
in the world by far and but 2800 is uh
has been a barrier and a lot of players
are actually been falling out of the
2800 class at one time I think we had
maybe five or six players above 2800 not
no it's it's just a magn seems to be a
deflation in the 2800 Club Knight of
five on the board Peter and uh poor
Wesley uh suffering
uh any tricks a fantastic a fantastic
reversal of Fortunes today after winning
a a positional Masterpiece yesterday
converting an advantage we all know is
significant but you still have to win
against a very very strong player and he
did it very very nicely never losing
control and today to just get blown out
of the water like this it's going to
it's going to hurt luckily for him there
is quite a bit of uh uh lway in terms of
the rating race and Anish I think
mentioned that him finishing in a top
two here will Propel him to the top of
the
circuit uh standing so he's not going to
although he he actually gets overtaken
by Fabby if he loses right so he will be
tied for second behind Fabby leading on
plus two uh so yeah very interesting
situation uh lots to follow but in terms
of this particular position we we can we
can discuss the implications of this
result basically this is a this is a
result one implication is that he is now
the winner of the grand chest T yeah
absolutely I mean he needed a
catastrophe to
occur exactly not to get anything yeah
and mvl was there on 50% now Fabby is
plus two wow um Ali Raza did find the
move Bishop A5 it was actually the only
move Ali Rea realized he needs to do
this and now we are getting that
position after probably King B3 the
question is whether y repeats once here
to perhaps try to invite black to play
King f8 which I think would be very
attractive to most human players you
know getting it away from mating Nets
I'm sure in a blitz or uh rapid game you
Trot your king to f8 almost with comes
and then you think oh de de how do I get
my king back to d8 Al res are down to
down to 14 minutes here I think Yan will
be disinclined to repeat honestly I
think he would very much like to put as
much pressure on the clock here as
possible
uh so my suspicion is he goes King B3
here Bishop C7 Bishop A7 uh and once
again asks the question there is more
than one solution which seems acceptable
King E7 trying to run towards like F6 G6
here the engine suggests is playable uh
I mentioned the move Rook H2 let's make
another rather obvious move G5 G4 G5 you
probably uh almost lost because ed5 ed5
King E7 is now not quick enough the
engine goes Knight D4 oh even Knight D4
Knight D4 and then all the threats to
your pieces like you would like to play
King F6 but that immediately loses
material to Bishop
D7 nasty I like this Rook H2 idea with a
simple idea that when D5 comes you're
ready to seize the defensive with Rook
H6 that as well blockade the the D6 so
Rook could you put Rook H2 on the board
there Peter sure I let me find let me
find my FL you're you're right here I
know but we already we already have it
on file somewhere but I can't find it I
like I like keeping everything in one
place but I seem to have displayed my
Bishop it's oh no the inclusion yeah the
so Rook H2 D5 takes takes and I like
your Rook H6 if you're going to if
you're going to stop the pawn stop the
pawn I said I didn't nope need to play
actively you you you can I think one
conclusion we can sort of make from
watching the engine play this perfectly
is black pretty much never has time to
to play passively you you you you
absolutely need to start with this check
and then after the King goes somewhere
if it goes on the C file the king C4 is
a playable move here but that allows us
a chance to play Bishop B6 check and
finally and finally trade something off
the board which allows us to Breeze
exactly a sigh of relief and if it goes
to the a
file let's say King uh A2 the engine
goes take stakes and plays specifically
Rook A8 once again to try and it gives
herself I think maybe importantly the C8
Square for the king and after Knight G4
I don't know how findable this is Rook
H4 is strictly the only move in this
position wow wow strictly the only move
why is
it you want a knight E6 check Bishop A6
you want to play Rook
A4 wow yeah I think I think that's
probably it if we play G4 here uh Bishop
6 is even stronger somehow but also
Knight C6 is winning and it's exactly as
yaser is saying here Bishop basic is
very strong and you would very much like
play teleport
Rook well this is not trivial this is
not trivial at all wow by the way I mean
if you look at the that final position
with the Rook the two Bishops and the
Knight it's kind of a harmonic
convergence of whites pieces all on your
abely uh if the game were to end there
by the way again I mean for Ali Raza I
mean this is really uh it's gone so
tragically WR uh two losses in a
row uh from his exalted position and
he's under pressure to find only moves
after playing this tabia for 27 moves uh
not exactly what he had in mind AB
coming in today's game what was
unbelievable about this particular tabia
was there was so many draws right but
this position is like massively
complicated truly truly and again just
coming into Studios we were told Joie
that Ali Raza had been
streaming his title Tuesday performance
expecting that he was having a free day
no he was not he was actually playing it
and he is playing and that quote about
Yan preparing for him what was that
about tell seems like seems like Yan did
prepare for
him I guess he did uh explain that to
the audience be there was some
going on stream you know you get asked
questions and I'm sure it was like
tongue and cheek you know he don't you
have to prepare for exctly and he says
no you know I don't prepare for nepo
nepo prepares for me you know got get
the psychology no no no lies detected
watching this absolutely no lies
detected so nepo did prepare for him
very
well and uh let's just check again uh
the sinkfield cup
standings GCT standings sorry uh as uh
we think with a victory today it's all
assured yeah it's in the bag uh with a
victory today Fabiana Caron you see
already he has 33 grandchester points
he's 11 ahead of Maxim bash graph he
needed a disaster everything to go wrong
for him to finish in bottom place but
plus two anywhere near the top half he's
got a he's got
a I want to ask Ben Underwood to to do a
little bit of research here cuz I'm
wondering if Faby wins this will this be
a record for the top score for the tour
because will be will be 46 points and 46
points is quite a lot of points you he
would have won Bucharest the other
classical event he would have won the
singfield cup a classical event he did
well in the rapid and Blitz yeah yeah I
would say it's uh it would be a
event and uh we do have a very
interesting graphic uh lethal winners
stubborn losers so take a look at the
average move count of winning games so
these are the players who have won Games
33 victories by peruja no no that's 33
moves yeah ah in the games that he's won
he's moved them quickly 33 he's NE the
grinder I wouldn't have guessed that I
would have guessed he was like a the
Abracadabra man no but that that's the
thing I think people kind of don't
realize about about him he is a very
good technical player and he actually
enjoys it and does it well winning
winning slightly better positions by
continuing to ask questions and then the
other side of it the flip side the flip
side yeah oh Dominguez
Untouchable of course these are just the
bottom the bottom bot bu cup got a big
fat zero there
lanir Fabby so Fabby loses quickly
quicker than everybody else
quicker Wesley but still 44 moves is a
lot of time so Peter I'm sorry I missed
your name there I don't I don't count
what and then we can see some
interesting stats again peruja only has
three singfield Cup wins whereas reports
has only one singfield cup win right and
Dominguez he is Untouchable he never
lost a game in the singfield I feel this
is a bit misleading though because fua
only has three sinkfield Cup wins this
is his second year playing and he has
none here so he won three in the
previous event and people winning three
in the grestore classical event is I
wouldn't like I would have removed the
word only yeah
not bad it's not bad these graphics and
uh interesting statistics come courtesy
of our resident statistician Ben on it
thank you Ben uh Bishop D3 E2 Lanier's
last move and by the way uh both Richie
and lanir do have a reputation of
getting themselves into time trouble and
if feels like they're heading that in
their that direction Jo because they
haven't made that many moves actually 16
moves each all the pieces all the pawns
on the board and uh they only have 30
minutes yeah and this is actually a very
very interesting strategic point in this
game because uh suddenly there is a
choice here for black which I think and
re has already not played that move
maybe he will play it next move but uh
another thing that we might be a bit
worried about I will I will return to my
point in a second but Bishop G6 Bishop
D3 on the board which is a bit of a draw
fir yes and I would very much like for
this this game to continue because it's
a very complicated very very interesting
position with all 32 pieces on the board
I will be a bit disappointed if they
actually repeat with Bishop H5 B B2 but
the point I was trying to make is
generally speaking in particular with
the black pawn already on A4 and the
white Pawn already on A3 you think white
is trying in the structures to give mate
on the king side black is trying to just
collect everything on the queen side
yeah but specifically with the bishop on
E2 and once again remember there's this
really really horrible horse on on E1
the engine was suggesting C5 C4 which is
a move that would you would normally
assign like a double question mark to
right because you've killed off your
entire count to play on the queen side
you're never doing this anymore you're
never challenging the the the center
from the queen side but this is now
killed off this will be in fantastic
fantastic Bishop on G6 completely
unchallenged and also the white pieces
are so unimpressive you can actually
start digging with F6 you can switch to
the king side and the engine was saying
C5 C4 big Advantage for black wow starts
liking black massively with the idea of
let's say once again if we could do this
we would be happy but it immediately
lands basically it goes Bishop G6 and
then if the Rook goes somewhere right it
starts Landing F7 F6 so
ideas and and uh sorry to disappoint you
uh Peter but it does appear a repetition
no that's only one right they've done it
once but I would like to add a little
caveat to this uh C5 C4 when you analyze
these type of positions with a computer
the computer like nine times out of 10
is saying close the center grab the
space and it goes black is better right
and then you play on a few moves and
it's like okay oh by the way I wasn't
quite right that no what I will say is
that it wasn't saying let's say if we go
one move back with the bishop still on
the B1 H B7 H7 B1 diagonal it absolutely
does not suggest it here it is only as a
reaction to Bishop d32 that it was so in
love with it because here C4 Bishop C2
it's very happy with white it's it's on
a good diagonal it's not in the way uh
it also protects against the black
Bishop lending on G6 and harassing our
Rook on on B1 it's it's very very
specifically against Bishop B2 that this
was this was an option and I honestly
knowing knowing reard I don't think he
repeats more than once they both very
low on time this is move 17 it makes
sense to repeat once just to get closer
to the time control but I would suspect
he plays
on uhhuh well we will find out in the
next few moves whether the players are
feeling in a peaceful mood or whether
they are going to continue the game and
can we quickly revisit the action that
is happening in Fabiano against Wesley
because all the moves that we predicted
two move repetition in the game on the
board and Wesley's position is still
looking very sorry West is not even
there Queen C5 King G8 on the board Rook
G1 is completely winning but as I said
Queen C7 uh is knockout just just a
complete knockout blow because yeah you
The Rook has no good squares like you
can play something like Rook E8 but now
both Rook G1 is completely winning and
you can also continue improving your
position by playing 96 and then Rook G1
next move is just very very bad but even
if you do this which is maybe slightly
milder in terms of impact you're still
at the very least winning the A7 Pawn
next move it looks
devastating I mean here black can do
something like this and you know pretend
that the game is still somehow on but it
really isn't no like yeah this is not a
good like I wanted to Queen D7 of course
I wanted to say yeah now I'm very ready
to
play I don't think Wesley wants to look
at his position I recognize that right
because sometimes the your position is
just horrifies you you know you say
you're thinking okay the best thing I
can do is just simply walk away leave it
to it own devic this my tattered
position my wreck uh
behind now this is uh again I'm I'm
trying to
think we've all lost bad games that that
that goes without a saying but I'm
trying to think of a Wesley so game
where he's lost none come to mind right
it's and look at the CLE looking queen7
and there you have it look at the the
Precision on that man give me that
exchange on
B8 which I will happily capture with
check get welcome to take the Rook no
can't do that can't make that trade um
it's terrible I tell you what move would
come as a shock to fa to Fabby Rook h8
to
f8 yeah this position becomes very like
maybe you lose you're random right
exactly in a in a Fisher random game you
probably just lose to Rook h8 to fate
castles here because suddenly you can't
Castle either side and yeah you get M
for something you just get mated in the
center that's a that's a different
different
situation right the king is halfway
there ju just failed to complete the
move sorry uh sorry mate uh wow uh now
this looks terrible Queen C7 I have no
no uh suggestions um we do have oi Raza
playing Bishop A5 and it finally it
seems to me that Yan is actually he had
built up a a nice advantage on the clock
yet like an hour and some time and now
he's down to 47 minutes so for the first
time I really think that Yan has taken
some time and sorry to say but uh
repetition going on no no repetition
yes7 B5 I thought you were going to say
I'm sorry to say that there is no
repetition B7 B5 wow okay well with the
idea of uh just seizing as much space as
possible on the queen
side do we like this move though I
always like it because you know at least
you're threatening
B4 as in as in you just making it an
option for a later date yeah it's it's
perfectly playable and perhaps it's time
for white to actually offload some
pieces of the board it's not going to be
an easy choice but it seems like in this
particular position D Tak C5 might be
playable okay just to get get some
things off the board while you can and
also stop as as as Yanka was saying B5
is I think there's a very direct idea
here of just playing B5 before Next
Movement starting to really challenge
the white setup okay uh and if we don't
do anything about it oh and uh let's go
Wesley a quick Shake of the head he
didn't see an answer to Queen C7 and he
resigned and uh well there we see
Fabiana Carana winning in how many moves
24 I think sorry got wrong moves sry
what a game there from Fabiana Carana
what a disappointment from Wesley it
just went wrong from the opening and one
big mistake just set off a catalyst for
more bad decisions uh like you said a
little knowledge uh was a bad thing this
move B7 B6 Miss time I mean Wesley knew
he needed play B6 in some variation
overlooked Queen F3 Queen F3 land on the
board and it was
splat absolutely and yeah with that uh
the rating race hits up uh and the
implications of this for both the
circuit race and the rating race are
something that we can discuss for for a
very long time because I think both have
become uh a lot closer
M yes they have by the way uh his Fab's
road ahead uh he's playing two of the
players who actually not perform
performing very well Joi mhm yeah he's
just defeated wsy so but huge Victory
will be playing Anish Gary tomorrow and
then Richard reports to finish the event
exactly and he's looking fabulous uh
plus two he essentially with this
Victory he sealed the deal he's now our
grand chestor champion uh 2023 so our
congratulations to him still everything
to play for in the cup Wesley's fans
will be disappointed but he's still plus
one and still you know one game
remaining because he does have bu in the
ninth and Final Round exactly but
anything can happen that's what we've
seen you know someone takes the lead and
then maybe you know you never know Anish
might play the role of spoiler put it in
context to for us this is a a huge
victory for Fabby again I mean it's just
crazy it's all G it's just a a fantastic
year maybe one of the one of the best
year not best year of his career but uh
he and I think maybe this is part of the
reason why he's playing so well he
doesn't actually need it anymore he is
more or less assured of winning the
grand chest tour he needed to play okay
he didn't really need to win the
tournament he need to play fine and he
already has qualified for for the
candidates so he is pretty much you know
free to roam here free to express
himself whereas half of half of the
field are still scrambling to qualify
for the candidates so for them it's a
lot more important and perhaps there is
more pressure on them and specifically
like on Wesley and and Anish who are uh
locked in that race for for the final
spot exactly uh but yeah for Wesley uh
this makes his certain qualification
somewhat questionable but the
interesting part is I think despite the
gap between him and Wesley closing down
I think Anish might be unhappy about
this
because I think Anish would much rather
Wesley was winning this tournament right
because then that would probably qualify
him through the circuit and remove him
all together from the rating
conversation but now that he might not
win the circuit and with this loss his
win in the circuit is a lot less assured
he is still five points ahead of both
him and ler in the rating race with very
very few games left right so I I get the
feeling once again my calculations I'm
sure I'm pretty sure Anish and people
around Anish are much more you know
conversing this but my base feeling here
is that this is probably not great news
for n despite his direct competitor
losing and coming closer closer to him
in in in in terms of uh the chase but
still some games left and uh we will be
continuing to update that story as as
results come in sure and just remind
everybody of what kind of a year it's
been for this it's been a fabulous one
yes and it started with first place in
the grandchester Romania
$100,000 for him came fourth in Croatia
also secured a spot at the 2024
candidates by coming in third at the
World Cup US champion Grand chess tour
winner of the Rapids St Louis rapid and
Blitz and now Grand chess tour 2023
winner the man we're talking about is
with Anastasia let's go to Anastasia in
studio thank you y sir you kept counting
money of Fabiano and we were watching it
so FY welcome to the studio and
congratulations on your Victory today
against Wesley such an important game I
guess for the tournament and for you so
where did you manage to trck him well he
mixed up lines in the opening I was a
bit surprised he went for this line but
I knew some details about it I think
yeah there's a theory that goes
something like here and then BC and the
point is a queen F3 Bishop D7 I think
this is like the point and there were
some games I think like uh Yan played a
game something like this bishop B7 Queen
C2 or maybe it's Bishop B7 first Knight
D7 I think Rook F D1 against kuk I
forget how it went but this was some
game um Yan was black against kuk and so
yeah this move was uh not very good and
then he yeah then when he played B6 I
understood he mixed up because he can
still play like okay Knight E5 I thought
Bishop C4 is quite important M and I was
trying to understand this this position
but I thought that he doesn't have like
yeah I don't know B4 first or or sorry
E4 I think was my final decision that I
was going to go for yeah and if he takes
the pawn the problem is his Bishop is is
bad on A5 if he trades it he's worse if
he Retreats and he's losing a lot of
time and he's probably also worse but
here no it took me a lot of calculation
because first I was looking at here and
then Queen A4 but then I thought Knight
D5 or something
probably everything I everything but I I
had a feeling when I saw this queen F3
because the first point which probably
he misses before very nice somehow
computer continues here Bishop B6 I I
castle and then Rook
D1 um or actually maybe not Rook D1 I
see mistake but anyway I thought like
I'm certainly better here yes I in some
man it's a question if you will convert
it yeah and then the other sharp move is
95 but after Bishop C4 I didn't see how
because Knight E5 I give this check and
after Bishop D7 I take and queen E4 I
think mhm is good and I was trying to
understand the position like Bishop
B7 I think and then I thought probably
Castle was strong but I wasn't 100% sure
because a lot of things are hanging and
there's always some tactics here so yeah
but he decided to go for this I thought
it's very logical and then yeah he
should have played here here and now
here and then sack the pawn and okay
black will have certainly some chances
to to draw the game perhaps um yeah like
Knight B5 yes or what I wasn't sure
because I can play Knight B5 Queen A2 I
can play Queen I was thinking Queen D3
is very promising end game because here
I forced him to take with the other rook
and then I get like Knight A4 so I was
calculating something like this take
take and I think finally it just like F3
or no sorry Bishop C3 this was a final
important move so you have two Bishops
here and exra Pawn Yeah
yeah maybe he like some tactics he might
survive I thought he should go for this
anyway because here it just feels rotten
like I don't know probably many ways um
but you found this also nice sacrifice
Bishop of7 yeah no I think what I did
was very clean but of course everything
should be should be strong like the
point is if castle and Bishop B5 is
probably just winning in exchange
because I take and Bishop B4 and if E5
then Queen F3 I think simply and again
he's just not developed um I think like
one important thing I detail I saw which
really convinced me was that Queen C5 I
Knight E4 this ends it completely yeah
because it yes Knight D6 okay queen4
Knight D6 and Knight D4 queen I'm not so
fast need time to realize things I think
that after B5 it still required some
calculation because of course I can do
various moves like Bishop A2 Bishop E2
all very promising moves but of course
this is very forcing because if he takes
with the pawn then simply Checkmate
Knight E4 or Knight H5 I don't know
which I would choose but they both look
like Checkmate yeah and then here it's
forced E5 is forced first my like my
thought was to go for this I mean but
then I realized that it's not so easy
cuz if he takes and Bishop G4 I thought
and then F3 and he takes and Rook d8 I
think I don't know maybe it's still
winning but I thought it's like getting
a bit maybe complicated but this was
very yeah I didn't see anything here for
him I mean KN King j6 maybe he could try
to walk but not far away and take you
take on C6 yes okay like I didn't
believe this and then if see Queen E4 m
i mean like best case for him he only is
down a pawn with a miserable position
exactly okay I thought maybe he can play
Rook B6 here or something uh but okay he
gave me the second pawn and now it's
completely hopeless yeah now it's
completely winning five one second game
in a row how do you feel about it
finally you played with white yeah yeah
and uh no I I have to say I got some
good fortune last two games I mean uh
you know Wesley almost never has games
like this so yeah probably he was a bit
nervous because the tournament situation
is like it was his last tough game it
was his last black game with the black
pieces and if he draws this game then
he's probably going to at least share
first right exactly so um okay for me I
I have two games left but he only has
one left because he has yeah he has
already bu had buy um I had an N here
before and he said that tomorrow we are
playing against him and he said that
it's considering his spot in the
candidates it's better for him maybe
even to lose this game what do you think
about it have you thought about it no I
I after the this game I gave it some
thought and I realized maybe he doesn't
like necessarily want to go all out
because um if he loses it's very bad for
him yeah for the rating and if I win the
tournament then maybe it's not also not
bad for him like that that Wesley
doesn't win so I don't know what his
approach will be anyway I'll I'll try to
approach it like a normal game and of
course it's on him to make some maybe
strategic decision of course he's not
going to lose absolutely he said at the
end that if I lose it's just because I'm
stupid or something but not because I
really wanted to do it but he said just
we we we come into such a weird
situation that these kind of scenarios
are possible yeah of course last night I
was thinking of all because it's very
interesting all the possible scenarios
for the candidates because it's
completely open now like Anish Wesley
even lenier now has an outside chance
but also gcash um aragi I think has a
chance everybody param has a chance I
mean it's like completely wide open race
so it's very interesting because there's
so many events at the end of the year
like in December we we
have
do you feel you know comfortable I mean
watching all this and not fighting for
the spot anymore yeah I don't have to to
stress out or worry about these things
maybe for for example Wesley or um or
Anish it's actually not a good thing
because it gives them them some extra
pressure like in this tournament they
they don't have to think just about the
tournament but also about like what
happens for cand exactly yes by the way
congratulations you just crossed to sou
800 again
yes you see you're getting closer to
Magnus something what we discussed with
you before yeah no of course overall so
far it's been I mean still two rounds
too but so far it's been a very very
good event for me yeah all the best of
like for the next challenge Fabby and
we're going back to the studio yeah
thank you Anastasia and congratulations
to Fabiana once more because well Fabby
said it he managed to take advantage of
Wesley's nerves there absolutely and to
score a resounding Victory now he moves
into to the front of the table and then
draw between leavon aronian and Anish
giri and I think it's the perfect time
for us to take our second break of the
day let's do it and we have a nice
feature lined up on the community
outreach program about Chess in St Louis
so enjoy that and we'll see you in a few
[Music]
moments
uh so today's Community Day all the
parents of the US Championship are going
to schools around St Louis and you know
teaching kids um openings and games uh
tactics doing some fun stuff like hand
and brain some simos and uh we just
finished our first class and it was
really fun I see kids taking the um
skills that they're learning in chess
whether that be critical thinking
decision making skills planning skills
and I see them applying that throughout
the rest of their school day whether
it's in classes or sports or even just
how they interact with one another and
with their teachers I play with my
auntie myom my sisters sometimes on the
weekends like we go to the park and we
play they begging me to teach them I
like show them like new stuff like new
openings I show them that and so I'm
trying to see them get better and try to
beat me what I like about Chess is just
trying to have on and learn new things
and maybe I'll get more into it and
it'll maybe be my full career I heard
that if you play chess you make bad
decisions in life so I always want to
make bad decisions in life I can tell
you that they've engaged more in uh
critical thinking they are looking
analytically at moves and trying to
think ahead I like the um complexity of
Chess how you have to think about
everything every single move you make
like every move you make whether is
going to put your king in check whether
it's going to put put your anything in
danger whether it's just a move that you
make everything counts in the long run I
like um how it makes me use my critical
thinking makes me look at the whole
board I think it's teaching them to be
persistent you know we have a lot of
students who it takes them like it may
take a few weeks or even months in chess
club to master a particular particular
strategy or skill um and what I think
that teaches kids is even if they don't
get it the first time around or even if
it's difficult the first time around um
it's worth sticking to it well one
thing's for certain without the St Lou
chess club we would not have chess
instructors because I don't know if you
all know this but there is a critical
shortage of teachers and Educators and
especially those in areas that are not
core content area and because of the St
Louis chess club collaboration we have
people who come in here working with
students who want to work with them
today with the experience of The
Grandmaster community outreach day I
came up and I'm like well what's a grand
master and they like oh you don't know
what a grandm is and they were able to
explain that and they recognize the
importance and the seriousness I mean
it's a sport it's a profession and so
they're able to see things outside of
the sports that we typically promote in
school makes me feel good because like
learning stuff like this will help me
learn help me build my problem solving
skills help me build strategy and like
you know helping my
[Music]
brain hello I'm women's grandmas viim
janova I will be creating content for
grandest store follow us on social media
and catch more behind the scenes
content the St Louis chess club is the
Premier chess facility in the United
States we bring the educational benefits
of chess to thousands of students across
the St Louis area we also promote Chess
at the highest levels hosting all levels
of the US championships as well as
high-profile tournaments that attract
the world's best players become a member
and enjoy perks such as free classes and
lectures weekly tournaments and so much
more visit St Louis chess club.org to
claim your membership
today yeah um it's amazing what the club
has done for chess in general because
I mean it's already been 15 years and
they've done countless uh national
championships tournaments for juniors
helping your own schools and they've
just grown the game so much across the
United States I think if I look at my
own career and I look at American Trust
in general we're in a much better place
than we were 15 years ago and so the
contributions have been immense and of
course it's all thanks to uh Dr Jun
singfield and rock
singfield I would say that St lucious
Club is like a rock in the ocean of
Chess and we know that it's it's there
it is there it will be there I think it
sense a hope that the the game of chess
will always stay flat by the mere fact
of its existence I think it it it sends
positive waste across the
[Music]
globe the World Chess Hall of Fame
located in the heart of St Louis's
historic Central West End want to know
why chess has intrigued people around
the world for nearly 1,500 years stop by
and learn about the impact of Chess from
our three floors showcasing the art
culture and history of the game the
World Chess Hall of Fame has something
for everyone to enjoy for more
information on current exhibits please
visit World Chess h.org
St Louis the chess capital of the United
States it also plays host to an
award-winning shop dedicated to chess
merchandise All Occasion gifts and
plenty more at Q Boutique you can shop
both in store and online from quirky
greeting cards to luxury chest sets
there is something for everyone at Q
Boutique enjoy a shopping experience
like no other make sure to check out Q
Boutique stl.com for a wide variety of
gifts for everyone to enjoy the St Louis
chess club Scholastic program brings the
educational value of Chess to kids and
schools across the same St Louis area
active in over 100 schools throughout
the St Louis city and county the St
Louis chess club has been able to reach
over 85,000 students in both inch school
and after school programs we view chess
as a valuable educational tool learn
more about our Scholastic programming by
visiting St Louis chess club.org
education hello I'm women's Grand Master
R to janova I will take you behind the
scenes of the grest follow us on social
media and don't miss out on players
interviews and more content from the
playing
Hall the St Louis chess club is the
Premier chess facility in the United
States and is among the best in the
world thanks to co-founders Dr jeie
Karen sinkfield and Rex sinkfield the St
Louis chess club is a nonprofit
organization committed to promoting the
game of chess locally and
internationally we bring the educational
benefits of chess to thousands of
students across the St Louis area
promoting cognitive development critical
thinking concentration and analytical
skills the St Louis chess club welcomes
chess lovers of any age and skill level
to come and enjoy the game of chess we
also promote Chess at the highest levels
hosting all levels of the US
championships and the American Cup as
well as high-profile tournaments that
attract the world's best players
including the prestigious sinkfield cup
Ken cup and many more all tournaments
can be streamed via our YouTube and
twitch channels that also include over
2,000 chess lectures for anyone to enjoy
become a member and enjoy perks such as
free classes and lectures weekly
tournaments merchandise discounts and so
much more visit St Louis chess club.org
to claim your membership
[Music]
today
the World Chess Hall of Fame located in
the heart of St Louis's historic Central
West End want to know why chess is
intrigued people around the world for
nearly 1,500 years stop by and learn
about the impact of Chess from our three
floors showcasing the art culture and
history of the game landmarked by the
world's largest chess piece sitting
outside our front door the World Chess
Hall of Fame has something for everyone
to enjoy including various exhibitions
monthly concerts and much more more
whether you are a beginner or a
professional there is something for
everyone to learn here at the World
Chess Hall of Fame enjoy free admission
to our rotating exhibitions in our
Galleries and sign up for chess events
familyfriendly programming and art
classes and don't forget to stop by our
award-winning gift shop Q Boutique and
Shop a wide selection of Chess related
merchandise for more information on
current exhibits please visit World
Chess h.org
[Music]
St Louis the chess capital of the United
States boasts the worldclass St Louis
chess club and the World Chess Hall of
Fame it also plays host to an
award-winning shop dedicated to chess
merchandise All Occasion gifts and
plenty more at Q Boutique you can shop
both in store and online for chess
merchandise autograph Collectibles chess
campus souvenirs and much much more from
quirky greeting cards to luxury chest
sets there is something for everyone at
Q Boutique and all purchases go right to
benefiting new exhibitions and programs
at the World Chess Hall of Fame
dedicated to exploring chess and its
immense impact on art and culture
located on the first floor of the World
Chess Hall of Fame enjoy a shopping
experience like no other and become
everyone's favorite Gift Giver if you
can shop in store make sure to check out
Q Boutique stl.com for a wide variety of
gifts for everyone to
[Music]
enjoy
we are back with a coverage of round
seven of the sinkfield cup and it's been
a dramatic start already did have a very
calm draw between Leon aronian and
denish giri but
everything loed because Fabiana caruana
defeated Wesley so in a most impressive
fashion and suddenly everything has
blown up Fabiana Carana in the lead now
and when it comes to the candidate 2024
spots well now it's all wide open again
yeah because that loss uh that defeat by
Wesley has made the rating race that
much more interesting and uh talking
about lenir Dominguez being as one of
those players in this rating race uh he
has quite a game uh battle going on
between himself and Richie bring up
today Peter yeah B5 was a black declined
to repeat with Bishop G6 Bishop H5 which
were really not that worried about
considering how combative both of these
guys are right uh ler declined the
opportunity of changing the structure
here with dc5 played G3 black responded
by taking and playing Knight B6 which is
a very logical continuation this is a
fantastic Square for after all the night
Bishop takes G6 and H6 looks like the
most obvious move in the world but
sometimes in these structures they
actually do this to Castle sort of
safely because uh having the F file to
look forward to I think makes any
potential attacks on the king side for
white much less realistic but H6 cannot
really be criticized H4 and KN C4 Bishop
G5 and in this position uh I would have
assumed you just play for some kind of
B5 before before coun to play but the
engine weirdly takes on G5 and then
starts shuffling there is all kinds of
really strange shuffling going on
because I saw by screen the engine first
bringing this one over to B3 and then
actually sending the other one back to
C6 which really blows my mind I don't
understand what this is I like the
concept though of getting a knight to B3
sure but it's primarily just to control
SE line control the C file absolutely
but instead of this and I think very
much you know in keeping with what kind
of a chess player he is uh reard says
let's blow things up yeah right I I like
to watch the world burn and burn it
potentially might here this is a very
strong reply uh the point being I'm
pretty sure that after F takes E5 white
is not going to do the obvious thing
which after castles this is still
unclear but this is very playable for
black the king side is now vulnerable
obviously the pawn on G6 is now
potentially weak but the Rook often
comes to F5 and it's not that easy to
chase it away E5 is perennially weak
something like Bishop C5 Follow by Queen
F7 could be playable maybe hoping to
bring the queen over to F5 instead of
all that white will take with the Knight
and whichever piece you choose I'm
playing Knight D3 mhm and I'm continuing
to try to actually establish a piece on
E5 instead of a pawn and if that happens
if we are talking about some kind of
position like this these weaknesses are
now going to be a very very significant
issue for black with the queen coming
over to G4 a rook landing on E1 right
and I think uh Rich's reply here is very
much an indication that he's realized he
needs to now take uh drastic measures
it's a good move but it just blew up the
position didn't it's it's a full it's a
full Pawn sacrifice but he will after
something like this the engine suggest
this move Queen d8 because what you
don't want to to have to deal with is
white engaging the Knight on G5 for free
so if we compare this position with this
position with the other one coming to F3
this is obviously just so much better
for white in comparison so you play
something like Queen d8 you provoke this
trade and then the king I think will
pretty much always be pretty safe on D7
considering how completely logged down
the center and the queen side is and you
want to play G5 uh the engine actually
even castles long which is the same
thing but maybe it connects the Rook
slightly more efficiently so you want to
play G5 with maybe some ideas of G4
ideas of Queen H7 Queen H1 mate those
are good ideas very sound ideas if they
can be if they could come to pass they
would be very enjoyable for black preach
into the choir here yeah right so this
is this is a very very exciting game now
after G5 yeah but again uh for me
uh this Pawn sacrifice that Richard is
embarking on Al began with the move F7
F6 yeah he didn't have to go in this
direction at all he was having a very
peaceful life and uh whoa okay hang on a
second what he snapped to on5 here what
this is very
confusing
okay this I don't think is great and I
think I wouldn't think it's great even
if I didn't know that the engine screams
at it Knight D3
uh let me check what the difference is
if I do this and Knight D3 ah he's given
himself the option of playing Bishop
takes G5 here which is an important
thing because after Bishop takes E5 for
instance we can now play queen7 and
we've removed the H4 Pawn from the board
meaning that The Rook on h8 is playing
but after F5 now the engine says we can
take first with the bishop and then with
the with the pawn and G5 survived if you
take Knight takes E5 after Queen E2 you
your entire position is hanging your
entire position is hanging E5 is hanging
B5 is hanging if you trade E6 E6 is very
much hanging you don't want to that so
very importantly I think we actually now
want to and D5 played okay we're not
guessing any moves this is still good
for white but I think Bishop takes E5
okay so can we just run through that
line again
so Bishop no not Bishop takes E5 but the
the other one where there's Bishop takes
G5 okay so Knight E5 we we take I think
this
Knight to D3 Bishop takes even here D5
is pretty strong but if we want to
continue doing what we were doing in the
previous line mhm Bishop this wins the
pawn back and tries to unpin unpin the
Knight on E5 okay yeah they're playing
very quickly because neither of them has
a lot of time Richard is actually down
to 7 Minutes weirdly for us in this
tournament ler is actually in control on
the clock with a with a whopping 20
minutes on the clock there he's serious
yeah yeah yeah D5 played and Richard
instantly plays Bishop Bishop C5
transferring it over to the B6 square
and then hoping to launch some kind of
an attack on the king side let's say KN
D3 I guess he goes Bishop B6 prepping
long castles where the bishop will
secure the king and here I feel it's
actually important for white to play G5
G6 just denying the F7 square and also
very much establishing our own play
against the pawn on E6 this isn't
objectively particularly good for black
but it's still a very very messy
position which is very possible to play
not much time on the clocks uh
for in this one 27 moves have been
played Bishop C5 I like White's position
uh a lineer uh with the position could
implode for either side eily easily yes
right you know the price of an arrow
here is going to be very high I I like
the plan of castling quickly to the
queen side run to the Seas yes for black
um we haven't talked enough about the
nepo game because that game yeah
uh bring us up to date with what has
happened Peter so in the position that
we had on the board when we last talked
about it before the Fabby interview we
were discussing the move King B3 here
which we thought was very critical but
uh Yan went for something that is also
very very logical establishing this very
beautiful looking Bishop PA D6 this
whole construction is now very immobile
for black nothing really moves yeah the
issue for white here and I think the
reason why we aren't really winning here
with white is pretty simply we're a long
way away from a threat mhm uh we're
pinned along the second Rank and after
something like G5 G4 white needs to
actually invest the tempo in something
like King B3 and now the threat would be
to play D4 D5 move this Pawn away and
play Knight D4 with intentions of play
Maybe E6 maybe knight6 check those are
very legitimate threats but you can play
G3 and now after D5 black is very simply
in time to generate this very very
important passer and it doesn't win
because white always has a bailout with
Bishop C5 white can even include D takes
C6 G1 will be ill advised because white
actually gets there the not only
promotes it promotes with check check so
you don't get M on the other side of the
check first wins the game all that uh
but after F takes C6 once again for
white you know it's time to play Bishop
C5 and the simplest here is just to
trade the Rooks right then you you pick
up the pawn on E5 and these positions
are very very trivy drawn even without
these two pawns the the structure is
very simple you bring the king in the
corner you put the bishop in the other
corner and you say please give me a
check from somewhere sir right uh this
is not very difficult right uh and alzo
had this option or the option that he
chose which was to play F6 uh which uh
removes more pawns from the board and
also obviously allowing Knight D4 might
be risky even though engine apparently
says you can even go G7 G6 here and
nothing bad is going to happen to us wow
but not a lot it all together I think is
a much more understandable decision yeah
and Yan has been thinking for quite some
time in this position trying to find a
threat to generate and I think he's
coming up short he's definitely not
worse MH uh but with a knight on E2
really only wanting to go to D4 and that
square being denied to it I'm not sure
what Black's next move is maybe if he
gives up on this whole kind of keeping
black in a bind I was thinking Bishop C4
no Bishop C4 yeah you can't play at all
yeah this is another this is another
problem there aren't really very many
moves that show that to our Audience by
the way C just both Bishop D6 and uh
Rook C4 is even cleaner yeah with the
idea of this being this being a discover
check now in Black winds oops Yeah so
well for me I mean okay I can't play
knight4 yeah I would love to play Knight
C5 so how how are we getting there it's
a C3 C3 and then A4 C5 yeah now first of
all this I think makes this makes an
immediate draw but I suspect maybe even
this doesn't no this actually loses to
Knight A4 you're absolutely right this
is a very strong threat I I was trying
to get the Knight active but I mean The
Rook C Rook G3 really if King moves to
we will be thinking C3
EXA exactly the same mechanism second
time twice but then I've learned the
third every mistake at least twice Joy
that's it and uh interesting mechanism
here for for making a draw here for
White is you always have this check from
C7 in these types of positions you will
actually not enjoy the position after
Rook D6 let's say King F7 all that much
because if anyone is playing for a win
here it's probably black but you have
the you have the immediate draw here
with Rook C7 and then back to D7 and
then back to C7 and so on and so forth
but Yan finally settled on a move he
played Bishop C5 and now the simplest
ones again is just to say get the let's
get rid of the Rooks he will do this in
response obviously we're not giving the
exchange while the E5 Pawn is still
alive but there is a number sorry Knight
C6 check I was wondering why the E5
peski wow yeah engine says engine says
we just play King C8 and now we're ready
to take on E5 next move PA white has
this Perpetual on a65 squares but not
very much else Rook B8 already on the
board by the way so let's go back to the
position with more pieces if I'm in Ali
Ra's shoes I played the move Rook B8 I
feel this great sense of Rel like
you know getting rid of that Rook that
Rook was threatening to Checkmate me all
of those times on G8 on D7 on me and
getting rid of it what a a great success
Knight D4 on the board for play yeah
King C8 is the cleanest but you can also
probably include some checks with the
Rook first I just don't see why you
would need to right we need to sidestep
like we need to S side step the Knight
Forks we need to create a threat of
taking on E5 so I thinking C8 is just a
very very logical move here agreed
wholeheartedly King C8 and joy what is
going on in the Richie Rapport game
because we do have G6 as advertised by
Peter on the board lanir with 17 minutes
it it's so strange for me to think of
lanir as
having I've got I've got yeah first of
all more but it's like 12 minutes more
time I mean Lanier's fans must be
cheering and also feeling like this is
really unusual well yesterday we saw him
leave himself with one second to spare
before playing well he did come on the
show well uh I didn't intend for that to
happen
apologies which honestly makes it
scarier right like how do you forget
that you've got one second you just you
get absorbed in into the position right
you know he was comfortably working out
RI G8 ricky4 and you know was just
completely in a trance and then he looks
at the clock and realizes oh oh my
goodness me to make a move no no no he
he told us he made a move without
looking and then looked up and realized
he has 31 seconds left yes and that is
how you lose on time because if at no
point does it occur to you to even look
he told us he thought he had a lot of
time right which clearly he hasn't it
went past uh G5 G6 and this is a
reminder to Richie that uh you're not
going to have your way on the king side
you've put your Bishop on B6 so of
course you're posing uh the uh King on
G1 the yes the H files open but uh
essentially lanir is saying I want to
play the move Knight G5 furthermore I
want G Queen G4 hitting the pawn on E6
and thanks to the G6 Pawn I now have a
stepping stone meaning you're not going
to double your Rooks on the H file that
easily anytime soon yeah so Knight
pardon me G5 G6 it says to Richie you
pay attention Knight G5 Knight we can
probably watch the handshake in real
time on the other board so we could do
that I guess Swit to in Neo's game
because the repetition and I just see
Neo's body posture is yeah he's he's
reconciled himself to a draw now players
are
repeating explain this in a kind of a
context uh because great preparation by
neppo clearly he put some serious effort
into this opening and his preparation
for today he's not being rewarded Peter
no it's it's a bit strange though
because I'm pretty sure he knows that
the evaluation of this whole line is
still equal if black plays perfectly I
think the reason he is sort of upset is
what ala did is not absolutely the
prescribed the way to make that draw he
knows that some moves which are in the
first line have been played right so he
feel feels maybe he missed something
which resembles a win I think he will be
modified once he gets back to the room
and if our machine isn't very wrong and
the cloud machines aren't suggesting
something other completely different he
was never winning he was pressing
pressing but he was never I winning I
don't think and as soon as he realizes
that I think he his uh feelings of
slight disgust with himself will
dissipate a very good it hasn't been his
tournament right because we all remember
the round two when he was playing lenia
Dominguez he had several ways to win mhm
and well he blew it he missed them he
missed them and then here he's got his
preparation in Ali Resa doesn't react in
the most conventional way you he must
have felt like he had something his
position was very dangerous well as
Peter's saying he's probably at this
moment upset with himself and maybe uh
will be less so uh MiFi as Peter said
and uh let's check out the results so
far and you can see there was a draw
between nomachi against fua leavon Ronan
and Anish giri also a draw but it was at
the top of the table where Fabiana
Carana played a miniature against Wesley
so to seize the lead yes indeed and just
playing through the game it you know
it's I'm looking I mean it's just a very
accurate game I'm seeing between yes
please can we go let's do it
against Richard game because I'm just
looking at the clock times and Richard
just under two minutes no way that
position is looking scary fast five
minutes that just uh heading to F7 so we
just saw the move G6 and we were
thinking Castle's long and getting out
of Dodge uh instead Knight E7 Knight G5
by the way uh lanir playing quickly
staying ahead on the clock Knight G5
gift me the pawn and uh questions are
being asked here uh Peter are we playing
King D7 well I'm thinking I don't think
so you don't think you don't think how
you're going to defend que G6 or or
something I think six specifically
because if you play Queen G4 you are
allowing D5 D4 and the threat of M in
one is something maybe that Richard
wants to create at least to you know
Richard ask a question yeah under the
minute Mark for 10
moves oh you can see the stress from
Rich he's not hiding that one at all
position is massively complicated Queen
C6 is what we are predicting and after
Queen C6 Queen G4 might not even be the
most precise way because if you start
with Knight F7 you are successfully
solving both the problem of black
castling Queen side and also uh the
problem of he's gone Queen D7 against
Queen D7 I think we probably do play
Queen G4
though with Queen D7 on yeah Queen G4 is
very strong Knight F7 is also massively
massively painful here for black just
well Chasing The Rook off also kn6 check
yeah I I love knight7 well if I force
Rook f8 don't I have Queen H5 by the way
isn't that yeah it's strong but I think
G4 is just a better Square I think
keeping an eye on the E6 Pawn is going
to pretty much always be a more relev
advantageous yeah just just like 4
immediately or Knight D6 followed by
Queen G4 and one thing I wanted to
remark upon the queen site is actually
not completely closed and once we get
the black king to somewhere like d8 you
can very much start looking at B2 B3 in
every single position there trying to
open an additional source of uh uh
concern for black this is just bad Queen
D7 instead of Queen C6 the move Queen C6
did have
D5 D4 and queen H1 mate on the agenda
Queen
D7 the immediate Queen G4 Peter also
very
strong it does it does give black a
chance to play Rook H6 which is really
not that cheerful H6 yeah not that
cheerful that's uh not a move I had on
my radar yeah giving up giving up on
the6 but at least trying to pick up that
pawn on
G6 how takes G6 Rook takes G6 KN G7
though I guess we go King D7 and we
claim that this is an improvement
sorry King d8 because it might be that
white needs to trade and then here where
two pawns down but the Knight on G7 is a
bit awkward we have to play Knight H5
maybe we play Rook h8 Knight F6 King E6
or something and we claim we have some
positional compensation we don't really
but we can claim it King E King King
King G2 it it still looks very very bad
I I I have I would say yeah but okay
um yeah this this whole line is very
logical and it remains very bad for
black I mean could F5 instead that's
Rook H yeah sorry uh Knight F5 kn5 but
he just really really hates allowing
Knight F7 Knight D6 is the point after
Knight F5 we go Knight F7 Rook f8 Knight
D6 check we more or less force you to
take and once you take the E file opens
the position starts really really
collaps saying yeah and you can't really
afford to keep that Knight on D6 alive
cuz like after King d8 we can also just
go like King
s KN F7 is very good yeah KN f s is a
very solid Choice
here big question for Richard what is he
going to do with his Rook he doesn't
have much time to do anything with his
Rook he's got 40 seconds and counting
but well you can't go to H6 you can't go
to H7 you can't G8 makes no sense so H3
it's Rook f8 probably gets met by the
check and then Queen G4 and black is
worth everywhere sorry say that again
please Rook F eight we give a check and
then we go Queen G4 but you can't move
your Rook anywhere else if you go Rook
H3 then King can step up to G2 I think
he's seriously considering Knight takes
G6 the only reason Rook of Faith isn't
on the board yet he's seriously
considering just giving up that exchange
and getting G6 Pawn six five and it's
and he goes for Rook f8 with two seconds
on his clock did he really intend to go
down now you see this is the thing lanir
is now playing against an opponent who
has 2 seconds on his clock and 30
seconds and he's probably thinking to
himself my God this is
wonderful stress that my opponent is
under I mean I should be doing this more
often from this side it's she's a lot
more enjoyable from this side somehow
and just to repeat he made this move did
Richard with 5 Seconds 4 seconds
counting 3 seconds let's purposefully
press our clock well done with 2
seconds oh I just hold my breath every
time they do that I mean uh Rook we were
looking at this position with Queen G4
we thought that was a very very powerful
position including the check is never a
mistake though Knight D6 check is also
very just to show one important
variation there which I think in
Practical terms just wins the game on
the spot you go Knight D6 check I think
Richard might be tempted to take and
take on G6 and hope that he doesn't lose
on the spot to Queen H5 Queen H5 Queen
F7 okay and it might look like we've
survived for a second Until you realize
Bishop B3 exists let's put this on the
board Queen H5 oh Queen H5 que queen7
and then Bishop E3 is just a crashing
blow okay I wanted to go D7 but Bishop
E3 preparing D7 is even stronger because
you cannot take because F takes E3
immediately collapses your entire
defense right and if you are forced to
retreat with this bishop white will have
a wide variety of finishing blows to
choose from D7 check followed by Vex G6
for
instance Pizza is
finally spotted my Chapo right working
on this tactics
helps doesn't it JY uh that's a nice one
and yeah I mean come on uh yeah so you
go L6 you also give somebody who has 30
seconds this choice and I probably
recognizing that line that you just
pointed out as a bust playing King d8
here yeah and then we go Queen G4 and
the problem for black is this position
has nothing has nothing going for it
except it's blockaded on the queen side
so that my king might find
shelter You Live and Let Live the Knight
on D6 and just go you know what king
king goes to C7 The Rook moves to d8
King to B8 the way you're describing it
uh Jo I must say you've probably
experienced a lot of chest suffering no
problem I'll live with the Knight on D6
like like you're not bothering anybody
this is this is where B2 B3 comes in if
if not for B2 B3 it would have been bad
but maybe you could I mean reach move 40
which is the dream by this point but B3
and you know this side also starts
collapsing like grp bc1 check here you
like after King B8 once again that that
move comes back cuz I really want to put
the
[Music]
oh that yeah it's just it's just
horrible and if and if you have to play
this then you know tolerating the KN on
B6 becomes a bit
less instead uh Queen H5 was chosen by
uh L was my first instinct as and D5 D4
D5 D4 played by Richard and now 96 check
is once again very very
strong and uh let's pause our analysis
to throw over to Anastasia with nepo
exactly I'm here with Yan the game
finished in the draw Yan please show us
few critical moments of this game um
well so he played slav which I I would
say didn't I mean I expected it but like
in I was like my first
uh uh first idea that he'll play slav so
well I knew okay this line is like a
long pictures line yeah like I think
there is like one of the Maines here
Rook C2 it's like Queen sacrifice
for Rook light piece and two into two
pawns which is you know roughly equal
despite computer say it's slightly
better for white so I had instead this
move Rook C3 which is would be winning
if not Knight E4 so this is pretty much
all forced uh just exchange everything
Rook C6 now Knight B2 is important
because B3 is coming mhm yeah and here
okay E4 was um like about the last move
I I I managed to remember so I know this
like slightly dangerous for black so if
you I mean if you see this this position
for the first time you can easily you
know make some inaccuracy so I think one
of the ideas was just to play something
like R G2 Bishop F4 and Bishop F3 check
King B3 and here King
E7 uh maybe maybe not quite here but it
was one of the ideas so maybe like some
some move here like maybe Rook F2 uh as
far as I remember it's just some sort of
a draw but uh well what he did I think
it's in precise already so here yeah
takes they have this extra idea of
D5 G2 yeah Bishop F4 so this is already
I guess dangerous in some way but maybe
it's still you know not still not lost
by Miracle so Rook C8 um Rook B6 my idea
is very simple like Rook B7 and
something and he played here G5 which is
sort of a nice try and uh well I think I
analyzed this position maybe a similar
one and some there there was this move
like Bishop B8 which was like almost
winning or or winning so I in between
like Bishop G3 and Bishop B8 I more or
less quickly opted for Bishop B8 but
maybe bishop G3 was more practical so
for example after A5 Rook
B7 uh F4 Bishop
E1 well it's it's hard to believe but
maybe something here should be should be
good enough to win but uh well I'm not
sure like say like Bishop D6 giving away
like the bishop but it guess I'll still
like black has some compensation because
of the pawns but well I couldn't really
couldn't really you know recall so
Bishop B8 was like a nice option not to
allow any counter play but then
instead um I guess he could uh he could
play G4 and then after Rook B7 Rook B8
uh I think it's pretty decent chances to
draw a game let's say if Rook
E8 some I know bishop move and G3 with
the idea of Rook E2 but inste he played
Bishop B4 and this is like hard to
believe but maybe this also HS in in in
a weird way so scary for for black yeah
but okay I didn't see so what I saw like
was like King B3 like Bishop C7 Bishop
A7 uh let's say King E7 here so well
he's trying to run away with his King so
once he go gets to f8 I don't think it
will be something special and also I'm
even not so sure in this EV relations of
their position with an extra uh with
like three pieces for two Rooks and
three pawns yeah if I'm you know Pawns
so also it was like some fun line here
Bishop E5 like I wanted to play like D5
Bishop
C5 and here let's say D6 it would be
like
winning uh with D7 but oh there is
always Rook C2 like always Rook C2 so it
never works so here should repeat and
also let's say if here after Bishop C7
uh let's say Bishop A7 if we trade trade
King E7 Bishop
C5 uh would be smart but the problem is
here he plays G of D6 he takes takes and
plays this and again and then here Rook
E2 Knight 22 is um under attack yeah so
that's also some tricks here black could
could only be better so yeah it was hard
to accept but
probably uh some of these positions
should be should be good but uh yeah
it's really impressive how far your
preparation was in this game I mean
thank you just I me it's impressed was
I'm also impressed that Al managed to
hold it yes at the end what do you think
overall about the situation in the
tournament and what's happening right
now uh well uh it took only one day for
me not to come to the playing call to
everyone play a decisive game yeah so
now I'm back hopefully the it would be
normal level of of draws but I think
Wesley did something horrible to do out
of the opening so I was quite shocked to
I mean
um so at you know at least he could try
like I don't know Castle after Bishop
takes C4 but I mean instead he decided
just to you know losing free moves maybe
just b day for him but I guess yeah
there is U quite an interesting run for
their uh rating spot for the candidates
yeah so like absolutely looks like
everyone is
invited actually it looks like that and
tomorrow you are playing with Wesley so
what do you think about
it no idea should first like let this
game go and then okay maybe I will start
freaking it about the next one okay so
all the best of luck for you tomorrow
Yan thank you for coming today and we're
back to the
studio you were interviewing nepo we
have big breaking news as lanir
Dominguez won his second game in a row
to tie with Fabby and let's let's have a
recap of what just happened if we got
the magic of Television working for us I
don't know we'll see uh we for sure have
it going to have it because it was
incredibly exciting Richard just using
the incremental time and there you can
see playing those moves 2 seconds left
on the clock and the problem was that
his position was just dire I mean you
cannot play with a king in the middle of
the board and here it comes Knight B4
attacking the queen 30 seconds left on
the clock and you were mentioning Peter
that the engine hated the position so
much
que allowing Knight B7 Richie resigned
after that move Knight B4 and it was as
you just said dire I mean it
was everything went wrong at the end and
it F7 F6 was a real culprit no but G5
was fine it's just that he had to
connect the idea of G6 G5 and we can
discuss it slightly better with the
board present in the conversation sure I
was very very certain it was a
positional Pawn sacrifice and he tried
to play maybe he thought he will win the
pawn on E5 at some point and if G5 H G5
fg5 was played his position was still
perfectly playable yeah let's because we
didn't really we didn't really get to
discuss this at length uh when I saw the
move G5 it I thought he's playing really
well because F6 maybe was unnecessary
but this was the proper reaction just
take on G5 keep everything in the center
extremely solid Bishop takes G5 as I was
saying let's not allow the Knight to
land on G5 so easily and after Bishop B7
Queen E7 I think in Practical terms
black just isn't worse you want to play
G5 King D7 uh double on the AG file
you're still keeping some even some end
games might not be that clear because
your counterplay on the queen side is
still very much valid this is anybody's
game but already after F5 his position
was uh in trouble D5 wasn't even the
strongest move but even after G5 he was
in trouble here and after
allowing the move G5
G6 he's struggling over the board and he
also had I think a minute and a half
here so in practical terms again
somebody who is as careful and as you
know meticulous in his calculation as
lener is was always going to be
difficult to save and if we talk about
the the final position it's just very
very painful to watch because everything
is collapsing the king is in the center
being attacked from every side there's
before G5 constantly an additional
threat you can't really cross the sea
file uh and queen six KN B4 yeah the
final you have to go back and and the
position continues collapsing whichever
way white prefers so it's a very
understandable place I think for him to
end the game Joy I mean the position the
the tournament just exploded I mean we
had you know three rounds of draws draws
draws and suddenly yesterday 75% and
today the fight for first place just
flared a new and
lener is tied for first with alongside
Fabiano Carana and I'm sure that has
also so shaking up the ratings oh that's
true as well the ratings not only is he
tied for first with Fabby in the
tournament with his victory and Wesley
losing I have a feeling he's above
Wesley in the rating list now because he
gains maybe maybe not above but they
they are in Dead Heat I feel around the
2756 Mark wow as we've spoken about
somewhere in the early moments of this
show if he actually gets the rating spot
he still needs to play if he is in
contention he get it so far because he
doesn't have enough classical classical
tournaments played within the calendar
year right but if he is very much in
contention which with today's results he
absolutely is he might be looking for a
tournament to play in December so
organizers out there no well we do have
the classics taking place in St Louis in
December it will be held at the St Louis
University uh slooh University the
classics this year but wow um we'll get
an update of the rating uh for sure but
for lanir uh this is huge and what how
does that impact the pairings for
tomorrow yes so I mean things just got
heated Richard reports faces off against
Leon aronian Anish giri will have the
white pieces against Fabiano Carana for
Dominguez he plays with the white pieces
against Maxim Vash lra who returns to
the board after yesterday's Buy Wesley
so has the white pieces against Nashi
and for Ali Rea fua he
will because of the withdrawal of but
let's remind everybody lanir will be at
plus two Fabby will be at plus two so
they'll be eyeballing you Wesley so will
be a plus one and he's thinking you know
I may have messed up my my my tournament
but with a win against
nepo things get very interesting again
absolutely yeah I about those
playoffs plus do you said yes a lot of
people have been mentioning also that
the top three finishers of the grand
chest tour get an automatic
qualification for next year's Grand
chest tour so this is also now being
very much shaken up and uh that also
remains to be seen how today's results
affect those uh those exactly but yeah
the last two rounds promis to be very
very exciting yes and uh we are going to
go on that note to Anastasia who is in
the studio with
lenier indeed ler welcome to the studio
congratulations on your second victory
in a row how does it feel and what
happened today yeah it was a strange
game uh I mean I I feel like he lost
more than I than I won uh but uh yeah
that's how it goes sometimes I mean it
was a very interesting position like we
again got a pretty new position from Mo
six or seven so I thought that's that's
fine and um but that uh that was why we
were spending so much time I guess and
but I play I mean I was hesitating too
much and I was changing my plans and
finally I think he got a very good
position out of the opening so I decided
to repeat moves at some point and he got
ambitious which uh it's very
understandable because his position I
think at that point was was pretty good
when he played B5 avoiding three times
repetition and yeah with the idea to to
put the Knight on C4 and just keep
playing uh but yeah I thought my my
position should should still be fine I
mean um um um I think this age uh this
when I play G3 now was important to be
able to play H4 after I take on G6 so CD
CD Knight B6 M so this what happened yes
and you took on6 yes I think he got
ambitious play playing this F6 yes move
this is critical moment F6 maybe is not
required um but I think if I I mean if
we trade the Bishops probably it's
around equal I that was my my um
estimation during the game but I wasn't
sure at all it's so um not a e position
to evaluate let's instead of it yes he
could take yeah take
95 I don't know I felt that I was uh not
doing too badly here but black is
obviously fine with Knight on C4 but
after A6 uh yeah because the thing is
that he's King yeah and G5 was um I felt
that it was too risky mhm um because um
after takes uh and F takes D takes E5
there's no
real um that's reason used to yeah to
compensate I always have this King G2
Rook H1 at some point and um yeah maybe
he can still uh have some compensation
but yeah I think I think uh the way he
played after Bishop C5 and then Knight
D3 I think this G6 was a very good move
mhm and after this is the moment you
felt that now you're better yeah well
already after uh uh I took the bond I
felt that I should be better and um yeah
but here I saw that it's I mean it's
simply um extremely good for me now it's
just a out material and huge attack
exactly yes and you managed to win this
game um you know now there are so many
talks about this candidate spot and
suddenly your rating is also became very
important all this standing so what do
you think about it have you discussed it
with your trainer like yeah it was quite
unexpected I must say I wasn't thinking
too much about this uh I mean I knew
that in theory I have some remote chance
but uh I wasn't especially uh thinking
about this I was just trying to play a
good tournament but somehow yeah things
are going well and it's always nice to
to be in with a chance so let's see yeah
tomorrow you are playing against Maxim I
think if I'm not mistaken yes so was
wide yeah yeah I have uh still two games
and yeah nice position in the tournament
so
absolutely I I feel that I didn't play
very well today but uh uh of course a
win is a win and U I'll try to to I mean
to play two good games yeah thank you so
much L and all the best of luck in the
last rounds and we are going back to the
studio for final words I guess Anastasia
I have a question for lanir if you don't
mind uh lanir how did it feel to play
against an opponent who was in time
trouble uh lir how was it for you to
play against an opponent who was in time
trouble tricky question from y yeah it's
uh um unusual a little bit but uh yeah
what I try to do is kind of forget that
he's T trol because sometimes you I mean
this old trick from from the childhood
yeah like you try to play moves with the
idea to win on time and just spoil their
position so I was um I was more happy
about my position than than about the
time but it's always nice yeah it's
always nice when your opponent is down
to to one minute or so so I should think
about it from the other
side was something unusual for you today
yes I guess any questions yes no thank
you Anastasia good luck uh um Good Luck
for you from Y and all the commentators
absolutely uh fantastic and boy did the
tournament just explode or what that was
just amazing wow uh first take a look at
our
PR our standings excuse me and take a
look at that Fab Fabiana Carano with
four points out of six alongside lenia
Dominguez who also has four points out
of six they are in the lead and then we
also have Wesley so on plus one who has
four points out of seven said the the
game disparity is because of young
Kristoff duda's withdrawal in round two
everything to play for everything is
hanging in the banners after to days
explosive round and what a day it's been
I know I mean I I couldn't have
predicted this I couldn't have predicted
I didn't predict this in fact did any of
us I wasn't even close this well
actually Anastasia and our grandmas VAR
akobian did predict that Fabiana Carana
would be in the lead but us three no not
so much not so much very solid on 50%
I'm happy with my I'm solid on 50% but
boy uh final thoughts Peter a very
unpredictable round where this is what
we'd hoped when the SFI cup it's unclear
why it hasn't started earlier but we're
very happy that it finally has started
and I'm just very much looking forward
to the last two days because there will
be so many things to talk about both in
the context of this tournament which is
now I think wide open right with three
people very much in contention uh and a
lot of people in 50% could could perhaps
you know play play spoiler and also the
whole the whole story of people trying
to qualify for the candidates that is
just like completely blown blown open
with a lot of people uh now in
contention who I think a month ago would
have thought no shot exactly no shot
whatsoever uh so yeah very exciting two
more days to to come stay tuned we'll
we'll be here covering it for you Joy
that was such an exciting day I it
pleasure kind of Joy it was to
commentate on all this section was
absolutely brilliant and we are going to
call it a night but thank you all for
watching and join us tomorrow for a lot
more of the action it's going to be
intense good night everyone
wow
[Music]
this has been a presentation of the St
Louis chess club any reproduction or
distribution of this content without the
express written consent of the St Louis
chess club is
prohibited